So Leute, bin ich wieder am Start, ihr seid auch schon am Start sehe ich gerade, 8.55 Uhr
wird in der Subbox gecampt, aber angeblich Twitch weiß das besser, Twitch sagt ich habe
null Zuschauer, ihr seid gar nicht da, obviusly, hat da Twitch natürlich recht, weil Twitch
muss das ja wissen, wenn Twitch nicht weiß, wer soll sonst wissen, ja richtig, direkt
gepiped nach von und zu ChatGPT, aber irgendwas spannendes die Woche verpasst, lass mal kurz
überlegen, war die Woche was, heiße Wochenüberblick, die haben doch immer sowas, sieben Tage News,
muss ich aber hier in anderen Browser aufmachen, ok was ist, ist irgendwas interessantes, interessant,
die haben doch immer so eine Wochenübersicht oder kommt die erst Sonntags, aber heute
ist ja Sonntag, man das kann ich mir jetzt nicht alles durchlesen, die haben doch immer
so eine, ja gut was weiß ich, war heiße blickste blickste blickste immer durch, die haben immer
so eine Übersicht, was gibt es, kennt jemand was gutes, so IT News Weekly Summary, irgendwas
gescheites, außer so die großen Dinger, wo teilweise, also man heiße es ja auch schon
ziemlich ja Mist zwischendurch, ja zum Beispiel gab es ja letztens diese Geschichte hier mit
dieser Sicherheit, habe ich euch glaube schön gesehen, mit dieser Jason, nein nicht Jason,
mit dieser, wie heißt das Ding, JWT, ist glaube ich abgekürzt, genau, oder JWT, Node.js kriegt,
wo ja auch teilweise Dinger drin stehen, und ich mir gedacht habe, also das konnte ich aus
dem Originalartikel jetzt allerdings nicht rauslesen, was weiß ich, da gibt es irgendwie
nichts gescheites, ich lese täglich mal drüber, was bei Hacker News so steht, so ein bisschen
auf Reddit und, ah Alter, Augen, aber ansonsten, ich weiß nicht ob diese Woche irgendwas spannendes
gewesen ist, wir können mal kurz gucken, Sense, was ist da, ob da wieder China-Chinesen Zeug
drin ist, Trended This Week, Docker OS X, LangChain, GPT, na was natürlich sonst, C++
und Facebook zusammen, also ganz im Ernst, wenn mich einer fragt, wie können wir Facebook
noch beschissener machen, dann mit C++, und wenn mich einer fragen würde, wie können
wir C++ noch beschissener machen, dann C++ und Facebook, also egal was du machst, du
kommst bei beidem oft noch was schlechteres raus, wobei das glaube ich gar nicht so übel
ist, es wäre realistisch, ja, da sind irgendwelche Facebook Implementierungen drinne glaube
ich von irgendwelchen Standard C++ Dingern, die viel doller und schneller und mehr Facebook
sind, Amazon beendet Amazon Smile, ich weiß gar nicht was Amazon Smile, ach doch, doch
ich weiß was Amazon Smile ist, Amazon Smile ist das wo du quasi mit jedem Kaufer spenden
konntest, wir haben wohl nicht genug gesmiled, vor allem Bezos nicht, er hat nicht genug
gesmiled, iMessage Exporter, YOLO V8, wir sind schon bei YOLO V8 mittlerweile, YOLO ist
so eine Gesichtserkennungssoftware, also beziehungsweise heutzutage muss man ja sagen, eine Face Recognition
AI, weil das viel cooler ist, einfach Gesichtserkennungssoftware, wer sagt denn so was noch, ich weiß nicht,
das ist so eine Projektbeschreibung, wo ich absolut keine Ahnung habe, was es eigentlich
sein soll, towards robust blind face restoration, was zum, was, das ist so eine Beschreibung,
ich hab absolut keine Ahnung, irgendwas AI basiert das auf jeden Fall, ah ok, quasi
ein Upscaler beziehungsweise ein Schärfer für Bilder, ok, das sieht aber schon äußerst
künstlich aus, das Gesicht danach, die wollen mir nicht ernsthaft erzählen, dass der Typ
da im Leben nicht aus auf dem Bild, der könnte so ausgesehen haben auf dem Bild, aber der
sah wahrscheinlich nicht so aus auf dem Bild, weil ich meine, AI kann ja auch nichts dazu
erfinden, also AI kann ja auch nichts rekonstruieren, was nicht da ist, wobei man sagen muss, so
das Upscaling, das hat schon ganz gut funktioniert, guck mal, es gibt, klingt nach Yu-Gi-Oh irgendwie,
ne ist es nicht, Duell, white, was, white, beast, ex editor, ok, dieses, und ein weiteres
Webframework für Rust, wo man dann im Endeffekt wieder nichts versteht von dem, was da ist,
das ist ja auch eine Sprache mit hohem Rauschanteil, das darfst du auf Hacker News nicht sagen,
da kommt die Rust Task Force und erzählt dir, dass nur mit Rust ist es gut und blazingly
fast.
Cibolone, danke schön für den Sub, ach Serious Marks, danke schön, ich glaube, vor 29 Monaten,
Cibolone auch schon 35 Monate am Start, muss mal kurz, Volume Mixer, muss mal kurz meinen
Sound ein bisschen leiser machen, Windows hat ihn wieder hochgestellt, deutlich angenehmer,
als wenn man so ins Ohr geschrien bekommt, ja, viel besser, hier die Musik ist glaube
ich nicht so passend zum Aufwachen gerade, müssen wir ein bisschen was entspannenderes
machen, ja, das ist besser, was ist das, Rust on Rails, oder wie, ne, ich finde, eh, ich
kann mir nicht helfen, ich finde Rust so unglaublich schwerfällig zu lesen einfach nur, man kann
das hier irgendwo verstehen, aber ich meine, ach es ist, also an sich ist Rust eine super
Geschichte, wenn Rust jetzt noch eine schöne Sprache wäre, würde ich mich da schon durchaus
sehen öfters, was in Rust zu machen, so, da könnte man von ausgehen, dass Videos mit
so einem Titel eigentlich nichts changen, das klingt aber immer gut, wenn es everything
ist, was kann ChatGPT, ok, du weißt, du musst eigentlich über ein Thema keine Videos mehr
machen, wenn es sogar schon die Tagesschau mitgekriegt hat, wobei jetzt, ich kenne das
ChatGPT Video von der Tagesschau nicht, aber wahrscheinlich ist das wieder so ein Video
so nach dem Motto, was kann ChatGPT wirklich, und am Ende kommt raus, auch ChatGPT kann den
öffentlichen Rundfunk nicht ersetzen, bezahlt schon weiter eure Gebühren, oder irgendwie
sowas, kennst du einen Frank Zehner, nö, hab ich noch nie gesehen, nie gehört, keine
Ahnung, wer soll das sein?
Wenn man danach googelt, findet man auch irgendwelche Fußballseiten, oder so, ok,
nö.
Bist du jetzt doch auf Windows 11, ist es jetzt besser geworden, ne, Windows 11 ist
immer noch kacke.
ja sowas in der richtung ob da wahrscheinlich raus also ne windows 11 ist immer noch kacke
ich raste jeden tag aus wenn ich dieses komische windows switching hier drüber machen muss
und sowas ganz schlimm
ja bin ich bleibt mir ja nix anderes da übrig ich muss ja windows 11 verwenden ich hab ja
gar keine möglichkeit gescheint windows 10 zu verwenden auf dem neuen rechner weil microsoft
genau das gemacht hat was ich damals in meinem video moment laut statistik ist windows 11
ein flop und jetzt passen wir auf passen wir auf ich hab's ich hab's predicted wieder aber
gut das war jetzt nicht nicht so sonderlich schwierig das zu predicten
am ende läuft datum sind kostet nix und ich persönlich bin auch nicht das ist super nice
ohne umweg mehr aus einem vision weil ehrlich das letzte microsoft oder das war meine einschätzung
nach zumindest windows auch deutlich zurückgefahren alter max schwätzt da nicht mittlerweile außer
fensterfarbe viele nicht hier alle microsoft und dazu werden normale benutzer auch immer
abgeschreckt wenn sachen um die leute zum umstieg zu zwingen ja jetzt was wahrscheinlich in
nächster zeit kommen wird wie bei so der normalen 0815 benutzer einfacher machen und
ich rede jetzt nicht von irgendwelchen gängelungen die microsoft einbaut um die leute zum umstieg
zu zwingen da erzähle ich noch ein bisschen mehr in dem video zu aber es ist genauso gekommen
wie ich das gesagt habe es werden gewisse sachen einfach unter windows 10 nicht angepasst
beziehungsweise nur unter windows 11 eingefügt die essentiell sind für neue hardware zum
beispiel das ist doch gb oder das ist doch gb in den gb den ich nicht verstehe aber
das ist in schibet keine ahnung wer das sein soll
wollte ich jetzt sagen hallo leute jetzt genau ja also ist stimmt jetzt weiß ich was ich
sagen wollte und zwar warum ich bin aus elf benutzen muss ganz einfach guck mal hier also
das geht unter windows 10 nicht meine cpu wird nur gescheitene windows 11 unterstützt
weil die cpu hat ja 8 beziehungsweise mit hyper threading sind 16 logische performance
course also acht performance course und ich glaube 12 oder so 16 16 ob 16 efficiency
oder oder low power frag mich nicht wie es genau heißt course also sprich der hat mehrere
cpu kerne die unterschiedlich schnell sind ums jetzt mal platz zu sagen und damit kommt
windows 10 nicht klar das heißt nicht dass es nicht läuft unter windows 10 aber es bedeutet
dass es performance technisch nicht richtig ausgenutzt wird unter windows 10 weil der
windows 10 für tasks also für multithreading prozess scheduler für der quasi dafür zuständig
ist wer wieviel cpu zeit bekommt damit nicht klarkommt er geht halt davon aus jeder core
ist gleich schnell und dann scheduler oder dann legt er vielleicht das spiel auf efficiency
core und sowas das ist halt nicht in uns weg der sache du wirst im alltag wahrscheinlich
nicht großartig merken aber wenn du performance brauchst merkst du es auf jeden fall und
deswegen kannst du nur sinnvollerweise bin aus elf benutzen was mir ein bisschen auf
den keks geht weil wenn aus elf viele sachen hat die mich nerven ich mein an sich muss
man sagen wenn aus elf hat auch seine ganz guten seiten zum beispiel ist so dieses neue
settings ding zum ersten mal muss ich sagen halbwegs benutzbar ich benutze das jetzt gezwungen
ermaßen relativ oft aber man kommt man kommt damit klar man kommt damit klar nicht system
sounds müssen bisschen runtergemacht werden keine ahnung warum das so laut ist aber kommt
damit klar ist schon ok leider für manche sachen braucht man immer noch diesen shit
zum beispiel manchmal genau manchmal muss ich noch hier in das menü rein und bei supported
formats muss ich hier auswählen mit was der über den digitalen output übertragen soll
weil manchmal mein audio interface der meinung ist es stellt sich um und entweder mache
ich es dann aus und wieder an und das hilft aber auch manchmal nicht oder ich ich ich
mache hier kurzes häkchen an und aus aber das ist halt so dinger wo ich mir denke muss
dass ich weiß es gibt ein setting in diesem normalen menü aber das macht nix das macht
anscheinend was also das bringt nichts aber das setting in dem alten control panel bringt
was also das versteht man nicht so und ansonsten muss ich sagen ist wenn benutzt sich wenn
aus zehn benutzt sich wenn aus elf genauso wie wenn aus zehn eine sache die ich auch
etwas fragwürdig finde ihr wisst ja ich benutze gerne verschiedene desktops und wenn aus
zehn hatte eine animation wenn man desktops geswitcht hat guck aber jetzt hast du überhaupt
keine animation mehr was etwas verwirrend ist weil stell euch mal vor ich habe hier
den desktop auf und switch jetzt rüber ich sehe doch überhaupt nicht dass ich geswitcht
habe auf den ersten blick das einzige was ich sehe ist hier unten dass die eiken sich
verändern also ich sehe überhaupt nicht dass ich gerade den desktop switchen das ist exakt
der gleiche also microsoft hat gedacht das muss man nicht mal mitbekommen unter i3 ist
es ähnlich aber unter i3 switch ich ja auch explizit auf desktop 1 2 3 oder 4 war das
windows tap die windows tap ist dieser expose view wenn du desktops switchen willst ist
control Alexa control windows rechte maustaste und linke nicht rechte maus rechte feiltaste
und linke feiltaste 25 tips die nicht mein microsoft kennt alles klar ok das kommt man
das das ist wahrscheinlich eh wieder nix aber vielleicht nachher
gachi bus gift gut dass ich da ein bookmark drauf hab leute sonst wüsste ich sonst wüsste
ich gar nicht was ich machen würde
3d drucker schreibt meine hausarbeit ja gut mein 3d drucker kann sehr filigranen
sachen drucken warum soll er nicht auch schreiben können interessant wird es dem seine handschrift
beizubringen ich kann es interessant
tapps nee nee nee nee meine tapps sind ja dafür da um ram zu verbrauchen das muss schon
so bleiben alter chat gpt videos nutzen echt wie sonst was ich sollte auch ein paar ai
tools machen so top 5 ai tools die du benutzen musst oder irgendwie sowas oder du glaubst
nicht welcher ai tools brauche ich denn
immerhin hätte früher wahrscheinlich zwei stunden dran rumgemordelt
ja war sonst irgendwas die woche chat lass mich mal nicht dumm sterben irgendwas habe
ich irgendwas verpasst das war was war denn irgendwelche irgendwelche sicherheitslücken
gewesen oder war irgendwie irgendwas mir fällt jetzt nix aber paper li was habe ich gar nicht
mitgekriegt ach ja ach ja if you use paper interessant interessant das kenne ich auch
gar nicht mitbekommen paper has recently suffered a massive data breach das ist aber doof
aha best password manager ist ja einfach gar
kein in der cloud
paypal issued a warning to the users ok da muss ich nachher mal nachgucken ob ich ne warning
bekommen habe wahrscheinlich beim einloggen oder
ok muss ich muss ich mal nachher schauen nachher bei paypal ich gucke mal kurz in die paypal
app da was steht
da fragt man sich halt immer wie das gerade so leise auch so großen lehnen wie paypal
ich weiß mein passport aus dem kopf gerade nicht ja mal gucken ansonsten irgendwas spannendes
gewesen die woche nein das ist nicht 123456 für mein paypal account 0w ich schaue mal
kurz ich schaue mal kurz auf dem zweiten bildschirm einloggen
was haben wir denn hier paypal einloggen ach miss ich hab hier nur mal einen alten password
save ich hab ein password manager ist ja das dumme ich hab hier nur einen alten save ach
ich hab's ich hab's ich hab's ok authentifizierungs sms alles klar so muss ich mich einloggen
schnell und dann schauen wir mal ob ich von irgendeinem paypal breach betroffen bin also
beim einloggen steht nix da es ist jetzt gut oder schlecht wenn man einloggen nix da steht
es wahrscheinlich gut oder messages machen sie geld mobil ok also ausloggen dann logge
ich mich mit dem anderen account ein jetzt mit dem anderen account einloggen gute frage
müssen wir mal schauen so und beim anderen account ist auch nix als würde ich jetzt mal
drauf tippen dass ich nicht betroffen war von dem paypal leak oder das paypal ist doch
gar nicht weiß das ist ja immer ist ja ist ja auch ist ja auch nicht habe zwei fakte
und identifizierung ich habe eh zwei fakte
so
Sorry, es ist noch so Judaism.
T-T-T..
Oh?
Naja gut, was willst du machen, ne?
Okay.
Hat einer schonmal einen Eignungstest für eine Ausbildung als Fachinformatiker Systemintegration
gemacht?
Wo einen Eignungstest?
Vom Arbeitsamt?
Falls es vom Arbeitsamt ist, weird champ, kannst du vergessen.
Ich erzähl euch jetzt nicht zum 180.
Mal die Story vom Arbeitsamt, aber du kannst komplett vergessen, was die dir da erzählen.
Was kommt denn, was soll denn in so einem Eignungstest, was soll denn da drankommen?
In der Regel weiß man das doch selbst am besten.
Welcher Fluss fließt nicht durch Deutschland?
Der Glasfaser.
Wo gibt's denn diese Eignungstests?
Komm wir machen den mal.
Achso.
Also sowas ist immer fragwürdig, je nachdem, was die da für Themengebiete drin haben,
aber ich glaub nicht, dass das großartig was bringt.
Aber wie gesagt, diese Tests vom Arbeitsamt kannst du komplett vergessen.
Bei mir ist rausgekommen, ich soll Schreiner werden oder irgendetwas mit Holz machen.
Keckel.
Ja, hab ich mitbekommen.
Also es gab jetzt ja letztens wieder welche und aber auch schon vor einer Weile bei Facebook
und sonst wie.
Die goldenen Zeiten sind vorbei.
Das heißt, die goldenen Zeiten sind vorbei, die goldenen Zeiten sind vorbei, klingt ja
so nach dem Motto, ab jetzt geht es nur noch bergab.
Das wird auf gar keinen Fall so sein.
Du wirst in Zukunft weiter massig Techniker brauchen und IT Leute brauchen.
Bei Facebook und sonst wie, gerade bei den Amis, ist es ja so, sobald es da ein bisschen
wirtschaftlich schwankt, fliegen instant die Leute raus.
Also da ist ja viel mehr, wie nennen sie das, higher and fire oder so in der Richtung.
Da ist ja viel mehr so mit den Wellen einstellen und rausschmeißen und sowas.
Da würde ich mir jetzt nicht allzu viele Gedanken drüber machen.
Insgesamt sind die goldenen Zeiten, was Technik und IT angeht, wahrscheinlich, wie soll
man sagen, da kommt halt wieder was Neues, wo alle draufspringen.
Du konntest ja da noch nie mit 10 Jahre alten Sachen Geld verdienen, außer du bist Mainframe
oder Cobol-Entwickler.
Das würde ich mir keine Gedanken machen.
Einstellungstest Fachinformatiker, okay, geht klar, nein, nein, nein, nein, ich will nichts,
ich will nichts haben.
Okay.
Einstellungstest Fachinformatiker, ich bin mal gespannt, ob da irgendwas Sinnvolles
rein rauskommt.
Die Seite ist so beschissen gemacht, dass der DARK wieder nicht funktioniert.
Auch schon geil, weißt du schon, dass der Ausbildungspark sagt, welcher Fluss bließ
nicht durch Deutschland, was hat denn das mit Fachinformatiker zu tun?
Was ist das denn, was ist das, was ist das, okay, also ehrlich gesagt, ich glaube das,
es ist irgendwas in Italien oder Spanien, nee, ich glaube Italien, ich glaube Italien.
So, welches ist die Hauptstadt von Australien?
Es ist nicht Sydney, man denkt immer, dass es Sydney ist, aber es ist äh, es ist nicht
Sydney.
Das andere habe ich keine Ahnung, der Chat sagt das, der Chat muss es wissen, okay,
wer war der erste Präsident der Vereinigten Staaten, oh, das weiß ich, es ist George
Washington gewesen und ich glaube, der Jefferson war der dritte, es war, es war glaube ich
George Washington, dann war es John Adams und dann war es Thomas Jefferson.
Alter, ich glaube, ich weiß, warum weiß ich, wer die ersten drei Ami-Präsidenten waren,
doch ich kann euch sagen, warum ich das weiß, weil ich irgendwann mal eine Serie geguckt
habe über irgendwelche Ami-Präsidenten und das habe ich mir gemerkt, ähm, was bedeutet
Fraktion in der Politik, ein Zusammenschluss von Abgeordneten, eine Bezeichnung für Regierung,
eine Bezeichnung für Opposition, die Mehrheit, ich würde sagen Zusammenschluss von Abgeordneten,
ich habe nicht unendlich Zeit, echt nicht, ach, da oben ist ein Timer, ach so, das muss
er mir auch gesagt haben, was hat das jetzt mit Fachinformatiker zu tun, das hat doch
nichts, welcher Kontinent hat die höchste Bevölkerungszahl, ähm, also, also ich würde
entweder sagen Afrika oder Asien, aber, aber die China-Chinesen gibt es sehr viele, also
insofern, weiter, ähm, was wird in der EDV, oh jetzt kommen die Fachinformatiker, jetzt
kommen die Fachinformatiker, was wird in der EDV-Sprache unter Backup verstanden, Backup
ist, dass man sich beim IT-Support beschwert, wenn irgendwas weg ist, Datensicherung auf
Laufwerk oder Festplatte, ja, wie heißt der Arbeitsspeicher eines Computers? Festspeicher,
genau, Lese-Speicher, was ist, sag mal, wir hatten dieses Zeug erstellt, dass es niemand,
der davon Ahnung hat, oder? Wofür stehen die Begriffe analog und digital? Das, also,
das ist schon wieder, also ich weiß, was sie wissen wollen, aber das ist missverständlich
formuliert. Analog und digital muss erst mal rein von den Begriffen her überhaupt gar
nichts mit, äh, Computerzeug und sonst, Technik zu tun haben. Analog heißt so, wenn ich das
aus dem Kopf weiß, quasi so viel wie entsprechend, entspricht, ja, so analog zu, so, also entspricht.
Na ja gut, aber wahrscheinlich wollen sie das hier wissen. Was versteht, was verstehen
sie und der SQL? Eine Datenbank-Sprache, Alter, wer hat das geschrieben? Das ist ja, dafür
wollen die auch noch Geld, Mann. Was wird in der EDV oder Partition verstanden? Okay,
das ist, oh, das ist richtig mies, Alter. Bei der Betriebswahl der Max-Meyer-Einzelhandelsgesellschaft
sind von 100 beschäftigt, 500, wie viele Beschäftigte dürfen wählen? Hä? 85? Bin ich, hä? Ist
da, ist da irgendein Trick dabei oder check ich es nicht? Das, das, das, das ist doch
irgendeine G-Bait-Frage, oder? Das ist doch irgendeine G-Bait-Frage. Also, G-Bait-Frage,
wahrscheinlich ist es 60 oder so, ich hab die Frage nicht richtig gelesen. Oh, was,
von 85 Wahlberechtigten haben 68 bei der Betriebsratwahl gewählt. Wie viel Prozent der Wahlberechtigten
beschäftigt? Was, das ist zu früh für sowas. Es haben, wie viele, was? 85%, nee, nee, 85
Wahlberechtigten. Ach, nicht 85, das ist nicht Prozent, das ist nicht Prozent. Von 85 Wahlberechtigten,
also, von 85 haben 68. Okay, ähm, also es ist ein bisschen, es ist ein bisschen über
die Hälfte so. Also irgendwie, was, was, was, was ist ein 68, so 70? Sind das 70%? Oder
sind es 80? Ich weiß es aus dem Kopf, 80? Okay. Jetzt über den Daumen gepfeilt, so.
Äh, sag mal, was ist anders mit Fachinformatiker zu tun? What the fuck? Ja, das ist ja alles
schön und gut, aber das hat jetzt direkt mit Fachinformatiker nix zu tun, oder? Was ein,
was ein Schwachsinn. Das ist ein stinknormaler Test, dem man für nahezu fast alles, wo man
ein bisschen logisch denken muss, äh, anwenden kann. Aber ich würde jetzt auch nicht sagen,
dass das jetzt explizit was für Fachinformatiker ist. Diese, diese, Alter, das ist doch Chebat.
Das letzte Video war schon, war schon Geschwätze ohne Ende. Wir, wir scrollen da jetzt mal
schnell durch. Okay, Tool 1. Das haben wir doch schon mal, noch mal. Das war das letzte
Mal noch schon vorgestellt. Wir haben das sogar ausprobiert. Wir haben das sogar ausprobiert.
Das ist so ein automatisches Präsentationerstellungstool. Das war, sag mal, wie soll man sagen, interessant
vom Ansatz her, aber für Präsentation komplett unbrauchbar. Tool 2. Irgendwelche Chat-GPT-Dinger,
Tool 3. Juckt mich nicht, Tool 4. Tool 4 hat mit ihr einigst zu tun. Alter, Tool 4 ist
eine Notizverwaltung. Alter, was ein dummes Geschwätze.
Okay, also was können wir uns angucken? Hm, zeig mal her, was haben wir denn hier? Meine
neue Hightech-Wohnung. Okay, zeig mal her. I know review. Lange keine Room-Tour. Meine
neue Hightech-Wohnung. Zeig mal her. Auf geht's. Boah, ich hab zu viele Tabs, man.
Zwei Jahre ist meine letzte Room-Tour jetzt her und seitdem ist viel passiert. Erstens,
ich hab neue Möbel und andere nicht mehr. Zweitens, ich leb hier nicht mehr alleine
und drittens, es gibt ganz viel neue Technik. Er hat jetzt eine Katze. Die ich euch zeigen
möchte. Unsere Wohnung hat ein Farbschema. Blau, grau, rosa und salbei. Ich mag wie diese
drei Pastelltöne auf eine gemütliche und trotzdem... Okay, das stimmt. Für Leute,
die auf Apple Design stehen und sowas. Es hat was, es hat eine gewisse, gewisse, strahlt
eine gewisse Atmosphäre aus, ja. Miteinander harmonieren. Ich hab euch die genau... Ich
muss halt ehrlich sagen, für mich ist es halt... Sowas bräuchte ich nicht. Sowas bräuchte
ich nicht, weil ganz im Ernst, bei mir muss der Scheiß einfach funktionieren und das
alles, was da ist, hat irgendeinen Sinn. Also zumindest hier, beispielsweise im Arbeitszimmer.
Alles, was hier steht, hat irgendeinen Sinn. Der Tisch, der hier neben mir steht, ist, weil
ich den zum Streamen brauche und Technikzeug drauf zeigen. Neben mir ist das Konsolen...
Also es hat alles einen Sinn. Ich würde nie irgendwie so einen komischen Absatz dahin
machen, bloß um dann da irgendwie so ein komisches Bild draufzustellen, so eine Kerze,
die nie verwendet wird. Okay, vielleicht ist da eine Heizung drunter, vielleicht ist da
eine Heizung oder sowas. Gut, ist Geschmackssache. Die Farbzusammenstellung hat irgendwo was,
verstehe ich schon, also warum nicht? Sieht aus wie eine Muffin-Form, wo man Kaffee reinschützt.
Smarte Schlösser, okay, da hört es bei mir schon auf. Und der Spiegel natürlich für
alle Apple-Fans, abgerundete Ecken. Wo kämen... Leute, stellt euch mal vor, wo kämen wir
denn dahin, wenn der Spiegel keine abgerundeten Ecken hat? Das sieht man ja gar nix. Das muss
ab... Selbstverständlich muss es abgerundete Ecken haben. Der Spiegel, der Spiegel, der
Spiegel, der Spiegel sieht aus wie ein iPhone, Altes, oder? Das sieht aus, also von dem,
so ungefähr von Höhe zu Breite, das sieht aus wie ein iPhone-Case.
...Helmen endlich nicht mehr. Wir haben keine Farbe bei IKEA finden können, die uns gefällt,
deswegen haben wir den Schrank kurzerhand selbst angemalt und dazu noch passende Griffe
von H&M Home gekauft. Gegenüber hängt ein, wie ich finde, wunderschöner Spiegel und
darunter ist ein Schuhregal von Made.com. Dieser Online-Möbelladen ist leider pleite
gegangen, aber ich hoffe, er wird bald gerettet. Neben dem Eingangsbereich ist das Bad. Es
ist nicht riesig, aber auch hier haben wir eine der Wände in Salbei gestrichen und dadurch
wirkt der Raum größer und gemütlicher als davor. Weil Pflanzen ohne Licht früher oder
später sterben, sind wir auf Trockenblumen umgestiegen.
Alternativ, wisst ihr was ich machen würde? Bei mir würde da einfach gar nix stehen.
Die Technik kommt wahrscheinlich gerade noch. Bei mir würde dort einfach gar nix stehen
oder im Zweifelsfall ein Handtuch drauf liegen oder sowas, was man dort braucht. Aber es
ist ja natürlich Geschmackssache, ja. Also ich kann schon durchaus verstehen, dass einem
das zusagt. Neben dem Eingangsbereich ist das Bad. Es ist nicht riesig, aber auch hier
haben wir eine der Wände in Salbei gestrichen und dadurch wirkt der Raum größer und...
Auf jeden Fall würde ich da wahrscheinlich... Klopapier würde da wahrscheinlich draufstehen.
Klopapier würde draufstehen. Wahrscheinlich wird bei mir auch... Eventuell würde mein
Tablet oder sonst was drauf liegen, weil ich hab ja immer ein Tablet im Klo liegen, dass
ich schnell was gucken kann, wenn man gerade sein Geschäft verrichtet.
Ladekabel ist auch am Start. Also bei mir im Klo ist... Also neben dem Klo, also quasi
auf dieser Seite, wo bei mir die Dusche ist, bei mir ist die Dusche auf der Seite. Also
wenn ich auf dem Klo sitze, ist die Dusche bei mir hier und da ist das Waschbengen. Und
ich hab hier unten ein Ladekabel für... So ein Multifunktions-Ladekabel. Thunderbolt,
nee nicht Thunderbolt, Lightning, Micro-USB-USB-C-Ladekabel, so ein Triple-Kabel ist da dran. Dann ist
ein ESP32 dran, in einer wasserdichten Box. Der ist bei mir im Klo irgendwie hinten. Ladekabel
auf dem Klo, klar, so dass man den Handy laden kann. Kann durchaus sein, dass du dich mal
aufs Klo setzt und feststellst, aha, du brauchst jetzt erst mal ein bisschen Saft, dann lädst
er auf oder aber du machst das Handy an und gehst duschen und machst halt Musik oder lässt
irgendeinen Stream auf dem Handy laufen. Also ich hab hier daneben so ein Triple-Ladekabel,
dann ist ein ESP32 dran, der macht Bluetooth-Empfang für die Waage, die steht Waage steht bei
mir hier neben dran. Bluetooth-Empfang für die Waage und noch ein paar andere Bluetooth-Geräte,
die im ersten Stock verteilt sind. Dann liegt hier oben eine Tablet drauf quasi, also ich
übersetz das jetzt mal zu meinem Klo. Dann hab ich hier ein Tablet drauf liegen. Gegenüber
hab ich noch einen Heizlüfter, falls es nicht schnell genug warm wird. Den kann ich mit
einem RFID-Tag, der an so einem Wäschekorb ist, einschalten bzw. vom Handy aus. Moment,
du fasst dein Handy mit den ungewaschten Klohänden an. Hä? Why not? Du sitzt auf dem Klo und
greifst dein Handy an, wo ist das Problem? Es ist ja nicht, dass das pure Sitzen auf
dem Klo deine Hände dreckig macht. Warum nicht? Du setzt dich aufs Klo, da legst du das Handy
vor dich oder das Tablet vor dich oder es liegt noch da. Ich hab da so einen Wäschekorb,
da leg ich das Handy drauf oder das Tablet drauf und solange ich am Kacken bin, guck
ich dann auf dem Handy und auf dem Tablet rum. Und wenn ich fertig bin, dann mach ich die
Spülung an und dann nehme ich das Handy. Hä? Wo ist das Problem? Ich versteh das Problem
nicht. Ich kann es gerade nicht nachvollziehen, was daran jetzt problematisch sein sollte,
dein Handy auf dem Klo zu benutzen. Ich mein, 90% der Leute werden wahrscheinlich ihr Handy
auf dem Klo verwenden. Versteh ich jetzt nicht. Mein Klo ist nicht steuerbar über
App, was ich auch ganz gut finde, weil ich hab's ja letztens gesagt, wo wir uns die CES-Highlights
angeguckt haben, viel zu viel Technik, die man teuer bezahlen muss und in zwei Jahren
nicht mehr funktioniert, weil keine Firmware-Updates, weil Cloud-Surface ist abgeschaltet oder so
und so was. Mein Klo funktioniert tatsächlich ganz klassisch, per Knopf nebenan, per Knöpfe
nebenan oder per Fernbedienung. Moment, ich zeig euch mal die Fernbedienung. Aqua, Clean,
4000 Max-FPS. 8000 plus Remote. Ja, da ist die Fernbedienung. Da muss ich den PDF runterladen
für die Fernbedienung. Wo ist die Fernbedienung? Da ist die Fernbedienung. Naja, das ist ja
das schlechteste Bild von der Fernbedienung ever, Alter. So sieht die Fernbedienung aus.
So, da kann man dann... Gibt's da nicht vielleicht noch ein schöneres Bild von? Ja, so sieht
sie unausgefahren aus, die Fernbedienung. Dann kann man die Fernbedienung noch aus...
Also so sieht die Fernbedienung in normalem Stand aus. Man hat einen Knopf für Spülung
an. Also mit Spülung ist nicht gemeint, dass man zieht, sondern dass man den Poppers gespült
kriegt. Also man kann Wasser, Wasserspülung anmachen. Dann kann man den Wasserdruck senken
und erhöhen. Man kann den Abzug anmachen und ausmachen. Also den, dass es nicht stinkt
auf dem Klo. Da kann man absaugen lassen, absaugen und ausmachen. Man kann den Poppers
föhnen lassen, wenn man möchte. Benutze ich übrigens nie. Das Ding hat einen Föhn
drin. Da kann man sich den Poppers trocken pusten lassen, nachdem man abgespült hat.
Mag ich nicht. Ich mach das tatsächlich am liebsten noch mit Klo ab hier. Dann gibt's
für die Damen Dusche und dann gibt's glaube ich Presets. Da unten kann man verschiedene
Presets einstellen. Und wenn man es ganz technisch ausgefeilt haben will, kann man auch die Heizung
ein- und ausschalten, dass das Wasser warm ist. Normalerweise ist es so, dass das schon
ein bisschen das Wasser vorwärmt, wenn man sich aufs Klo draufsetzt. Das hat so ein Laser
zum Erkennen. Wenn sich einer mit dem Arsch draufsetzt auf die Brille, dann erkennt das
mit irgendeinem Erkennungsvorrichtung. Aber es ist kein Drucksensor an der Brille. Es
ist irgendeine Lichtschranke. Erkennt das, wenn man sich draufsetzt und dann macht es
das Wasser. Nein, keine Klo-Brillen-Heizung. Es ist kein kapazitiver Sensor, weil man das
nämlich, wenn man die Hand über die richtige Stelle macht, dann geht es auch, dann heizt
es schon ein bisschen das Wasser vor für eine Spülung. Mehr nicht. Also Stromverbrauch hält
den Grenzen. Kann man auch ausschalten. Man kann die Temperatur hoch und runter machen.
Man kann einstellen, wie das Wasser sprühen soll und in welchem Massagedusche habe ich
noch nie. Nicht kapazitiv. Du kannst die Hand in die Luft halten davor. Das ist irgendeine
Lichtschranke. Ja, genau. Das kann man machen. Und das funktioniert alles ganz klassisch
über. Ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt. Ich würde mal tippen, Infrarot, Kernbedienung. Vielleicht
ist es auch irgendein Funk-Protokoll. Weiß ich gar nicht, ob das hier... Infrarot, genau.
Deswegen bin ich ganz froh, dass das Klo tatsächlich auf so eine Oldschool-Art und Weise funktioniert.
Weil stell euch mal vor, das wäre ein Klo mit App, mit Cloud-Funktion, mit hast du nicht
gesehen. Das würde wahrscheinlich schon nicht mehr funktionieren. Ich habe das seit 2013,
also 10 Jahre jetzt. Keine Home Assistant-Integration. Ich habe das seit 10 Jahren jetzt. Und wahrscheinlich,
wenn ich ein neueres Klo hätte, mit App und sonstigen Geschissen, wird es wahrscheinlich
überhaupt nicht mehr funktionieren. Weil App nur noch alles ab iOS und Android sowieso
unterstützt und irgendwelche Geschichten. Oder App-Entwicklung wurde eingestellt, neue
App-Versionen kommt raus, unterstützt altes Klo nicht mehr. Also die Chance, dass bei
neuerer Technik einfach die Funktionen, die man mitgekauft hat, nach kurzer Zeit nicht
mehr funktionieren, sind relativ groß. Das sieht man auch immer wieder an den ganzen
Smart-Home-Geschichten, wo dann Cloud-Anbieter pleitegehen, alte Produktlinien einstellen
und lokal hat es noch nie richtig funktioniert. Das ist halt für ein Arsch. Kann man das
Klo flaschen? Praktisch nein, theoretisch bestimmt. Ich lasse AI mein Klo kontrollieren und das
ist passiert. Das ist eine super Video-Titel. Boah, weil Pflanzen ohne Licht früher oder
später sterben, sind wir auf trocken. Okay, immerhin Klo-Papier drauf. Ja, ich meine,
es hat eine gewisse Atmosphäre. Es ist wahrscheinlich designtechnisch sicherlich schöner als mein
Klo. Gar keine Frage. Oder mein Bad. Das ist eine Heizung? Das ist einfach nur ein
Tuchhänger. Ah, das ist tatsächlich ganz cool. Das habe ich mir mal angeguckt. Das
haben wir uns sogar mal im Stream angeguckt. Da hat mir irgendwas nicht dran gefallen.
War das noch im Hintergrund? Irgendwas hat mir... Es kann aber auch sein, dass es nicht
die Waage war. Was haben die noch? Oder waren die das mit dem Urinsensor? Nee, oder? Ach,
die waren das. Das waren die mit dem Urinsensor. Deswegen. Ja, rein dieses Urin-Ding mit seine
Gesundheitsdaten in irgendwelche Cloud-Sachen hochladen. Die waren das. Deswegen hat mir
das nicht gefallen. Wir haben uns die Waage gar nicht angeguckt. Ich habe auch so eine
Waage, die über Bluetooth-Sachen überträgt. Ich habe allerdings eine Xiaomi Mi Scale 2.
Das Teil habe ich. Exzellent. Sehr praktisch, vor allem billig und überträgt per Bluetooth,
also man braucht keine App. Was soll mir das Bild sagen? Warum trainiert die hier, vor
allem überhaupt nicht photogeschoppt und hat die Waage daneben stehen? Wo ist der Sinn
von dieser? Das Bild ergibt einfach überhaupt keinen Sinn. Gar nicht. Durch diese Sensorstange
kann sie genaue Werte über die gesamte Körperzusammenstellung erfassen. Nicht nur die gesamte Muskelmasse,
sondern auch, wie sie genau verteilt ist. Und beim Fett... Coole Funktion, muss ich
zugeben. Wie empfängst du die Daten von deiner Mi Waage? Hast du einen USB-Dongel? Ich habe
einen ESP32, quasi neben einem Klo hängen, in so einer wasserdichten Box. Der macht Bluetooth-Empfang
für die Waage... Was macht der noch? Für drei verschiedene Geräte. Lass mal kurz überlegen.
Der macht Bluetooth-Empfang für... Das funktioniert schon alles, dass ich es mir überhaupt nicht
mehr weiß. Achso, ja, genau. Also, das Ding macht Bluetooth-Empfang für die Waage, für
diese... Wie heißen diese Dinger? Temperature... Wie heißt dieses Ding? Das Ding? Genau. Da
habe ich im ganzen Haus welche. Mit Custom-Firmware selbstverständlich, weil mit Custom-Firmware
mit Custom-Firmware halten die Dinger sehr lange. Also, ich habe jetzt den ersten. Ich
gucke mal kurz ins Handy, wann ich den ersten gekauft habe. Kann ich euch sagen, wie lang
die kleine Furzbatterie jetzt schon hält, die da drin ist? Moment, View, Orders. Ciaomi.
Also, ich habe den ersten gekauft am 5. April 2021. Denn ja, die halten viel länger. Ich
habe den gekauft April 2021 und die Batterie ist jetzt bei 40% von dem ersten. Und warum?
Weil ich sie mit Custom-Firmware geflasht habe und die Intervalle deutlich runtergestellt
habe. Standardmäßig überträgt das, glaube ich, alle... Oh, keine Ahnung, alle 30 Sekunden
oder sowas. Was viel, viel zu viel ist. Was interessiert mich in einem Temperaturupdate
alle 30 Sekunden? Ich habe es, glaube ich, raufgestellt auf 10 Minuten oder sowas. Und
alle 10 Minuten updaten die Dinger per Bluetooth. Also, schicken die halt Bluetooth-mäßig
raus. Alle 10 Minuten Temperatur, Luftfeuchtigkeit. Und das hält jetzt schon. Also, das wird locker
zwei Jahre halten. Ich habe es April 2021 gekauft. Das ist bei 40%. Das wird locker
zwei Jahre halten, was absolut in Ordnung ist. Dann kann man mal die Batterie tauschen
und gut ist. Ich habe nicht aktualisiert auf Windows 11. Ich habe einen neuen Rechner.
Da ist Windows 11 drauf. Also, dafür macht das Ding noch Bluetooth-Empfang. Und ich
habe im Hof noch drei Reflora-Sensoren gesehen. Boden, also, beziehungsweise Leitfähigkeit
von der Erde kann man damit messen. Da weiß man zum Beispiel, ob man Blumen und sowas
gießen muss. Wobei ich ehrlich sagen muss, die schmeiße ich wieder raus. Das ist ziemlich
useless. Ich fand das ganz cool. Ich habe da mal bei AliExpress einen 10er-Pack gekauft.
Ja, irgendwie Leitfähigkeit vom Boden ist das. Ich habe da bei AliExpress mal einen 10er-Pack
gekauft, weil es die relativ günstig gab. Ob für irgendwie 7 Euro oder so damals das
Stück. Da habe ich irgendwie keinen 10er-Pack. Aber ganz im Ernst, auch keine Sau. Wenn
man rausgeht und guckt, reicht voll und ganz. Braucht wirklich niemand. Komplett useless
sein.
Kühlschrank-Sensor, ja, genau. Ach ja, ich habe auch noch einen Sensor im Kühlschrank.
Das habe ich ganz vergessen dafür. Ja, genau. Sehe ich das richtig? Die haben das selbst
programmiert. Das habe ich dann erweitert für die anderen Geräte. Auch mittlerweile,
also wenn ich das mal jemals neu machen sollte, würde ich das mit irgendeinem Home-Assistant-Proxy
machen. Und nicht selbst. Aber das haben wir damals im Stream selbst gehört. Stimmt, ich
habe noch einen Temperatursensor im Kühlschrank oben, weil der manchmal ein bisschen rumspackt
und krach macht. Ich hatte mal eine Bedenken, dass der Kühlschrank irgendwann den Geist
drauf gibt, weil er so komisch gerauscht hat. Mittlerweile rauscht er nicht mehr, hat es
wieder erledigt. Da habe ich einen Temperatursensor im Kühlschrank gelegt. Aber brauche ich eigentlich
nicht. Also, ich werde den Temperatursensor im Kühlschrank wieder wegmachen und die Pflanzen-
Feuchtigkeitssensoren werde ich auch wieder wegmachen. Braucht niemand. Ja, so sieht es
aus. Ok, gucken wir uns mal weiter seinen Bart an. Sind wir hier stecken? Ah. So, das
ist seine Waage. Also meine Waage ist nicht so advanced. Das finde ich cool. Mit diesem
ausziehbaren Ding, das es von oben nach unten messen kann und wo was verteilt ist. Hat eine
coole Sache. Wie genau das ist, würde ich jetzt zumindest mal hinterfragen. Also, würde
mich interessieren, ob das halbwegs hinkommt. Oder ob das halt best guess, so irgendwie,
so ungefähr. Also, ob es sich lohnt, würde mich tatsächlich mal interessieren. Ansonsten
meine Waage benutze ich. Ich kann zwar Körperfett und sowas, mache ich aber eigentlich nicht.
Ich mache damit nur Gewicht. Gewicht und dann gehe ich wieder runter und dann schickt
das ein paar Blutdosen und dann geht es ans Homo-System. Im Homo-System habe ich dann so einen schönen
Graf, dass ich sehe, dass ich nicht mehr so pepo-fett bin wie vor einem Jahr. Du musst
mal mal vorstellen, vor einem Jahr habe ich ungefähr noch 18 Kilo mehr gewogen. Ging
schon sehr zackig. Und wisst Zerralenfett, dasselbe Spiel. Man sieht anhand eines 3D-Körpers
in der App, wo was wie verteilt ist. Zusätzlich kann die Waage die Pulswellengeschwindigkeit
messen, ein 6-Kanal-EKG erstellen und das... Ein 6-Kanal-EKG, die Waage. Okay, also ich
glaube, dass die Waage denkt, das zu können. Und die Waage wird, wenn du das richtig in
die Hand nimmst, vielleicht auch irgendwie so ein bisschen deinen Puls mitbekommen. Aber
es interessiert sich, ob das so aussagekräftig ist. Ich bin unschlüssig. Ich kann es nicht
mehr ausprobieren, aber ich hatte vor ein paar Jahren, das ist aber auch schon bestimmt
6-7 Jahre her, hatte ich mal ein bisschen Probleme. Da hatte ich... Leute, da kriegt
ihr erstmal Panik, wenn ihr sowas habt. Ich hatte doppelte Herzschläge. Ich wusste bis
zum damaligen Zeitpunkt gar nicht, dass es sowas gibt. Doppelte Herzschläge, Alter.
Da guckt ihr erstmal komisch, wenn ihr sowas habt. Und... Das hat sich irgendwie so angefühlt
wie, als würde es kurz nicht schlagen und dann doppelt schlagen. Hat sich ganz komisch
angefühlt. Es ist irgendwie unregelbar. Ich habe damals auch ein richtiges EKG gemacht
beim Doktor und da hat man das auch drauf gesehen. Und der meinte, es ist nichts Schlimmes,
soll ich mir keine Gedanken machen. Das hat jeder ab und zu mal. Da habe ich mir gesagt,
das ist wirklich normal. Das fühlt sich auf jeden Fall sehr, sehr merkwürdig an. Ihr
könnt euch das ungefähr so vorstellen. Ich versuche euch das mal zu beschreiben, wie
sich doppelte Herzschläge anfühlen. Oder halt so unregelmisch, doppelte Herzschläge.
Also was wollte ich jetzt erzählen? Ich versuche euch das mal ungefähr so zu beschreiben.
Ihr kennt doch das Gefühl, wenn ihr euch erschreckt. Stellt euch vor, es ist glatt draußen und
ihr lauft ganz normal und auf einmal rutscht ihr mit dem Fuß weg. Aber ihr könnt euch
noch abfangen. Und in dem Moment, wo man rutscht, kriegst du immer so einen kleinen
Adrenalinstoß. So nach dem Motto, dass dir dein Hirn sagen will, alter Bein, jetzt beeil
dich mal beim Abfangen. Also in dem Moment, wo du rutschst, spürst du ja immer so einen
kleinen Adrenalinstoß. Hup, zack, abfangen. Wenn du auf irgendetwas glattem ausrutscht
und wenn du nicht dran denkst und rutschst auf einmal. Und ungefähr so fühlt sich das
an, wenn du so einen doppelten Herzschlag hast kurzzeitig. Das fühlt sich ungefähr
so an, wie du jetzt kriegst so einen kleinen Adrenalinstoß. So ein bisschen wie, wenn
du merkst, fuck, ich rutsche und du musst dich abfangen schnell. Und das ist wirklich
ganz furchtbar weird champ. Kannst du nicht anders sagen? Es ist sehr, sehr merkwürdig
auf jeden Fall. Man macht sich dann aber, sagen wir mal so, wenn man beim Arzt gewesen
ist, die das gemessen haben und sagen, ist nicht schlimm. Dann gewöhnt man sich da
irgendwo dran und macht sich dann keine Gedanken mehr drüber. Das ist wirklich sehr weird
champ. Das fühlt sich echt komisch an. Habe ich aber nicht mehr. Habe ich nicht mehr.
Hatt ich mal. Hatt ich mal eine Weile. Ich hab das jetzt vielleicht ab und zu mal irgendwie
einmal die Woche, einmal im Monat, einmal, eins, zwei Mal oder so noch. Was wahrscheinlich
jeder hat und sich dann überhaupt nichts dabei denkt. Aber ich hatte das ja teilweise regelmäßig.
Richtig, richtig turboheld. So ungefähr fühlt sich das an. Ja. Auf jeden Fall, wenn
auf jeden Fall irgendwie merkwürdig. Und ich habe es halt gemerkt und ich hatte das
auch relativ oft. Da habe ich ein, warum habe ich eigentlich keinen Process Explorer brauche
ich hier? Und wie gesagt, ich bin beim Arzt gewesen, habe EKG gemacht damals weiß ich
noch. Ich habe sogar einen Belastungs EKG gemacht. Auf dem Fahrrad musste ich da fahren.
Dass das da vorne ist und das riecht. Ich habe immer gerne ein Auge auf mein Rechner.
Was haben wir hier schon wieder? Der G-Hub Client. Sieht doch eigentlich alles. Yolo
Maus ist am Start. Es läuft, es läuft so viel. Es läuft so viel Shit auf dem aktuellen Rechner.
Das ist echt der Wahnsinn. Guckt euch das mal an, Alter. Wie viel Scheiße hier im Background
läuft. Absoluter Wahnsinn. Ich weiß auch noch, wenn ich aus XP war, waren das irgendwie
so fünf Programme standardmäßig. Na gut. Ja, richtig. Ich würde sagen, eine Kombination
war das bei mir auch. Ich würde sagen, es war auch eine Kombination wegen Stress und
zu wenig Bewegung. Aber ich bewege mich ja schon eine ganze Weile mehr. Was nicht unter
anderem nicht zuletzt dazu beigetragen hat, dass ich 18 Kilo abgenommen habe. Aber ich
behalte das seit Jahren schon nicht mehr. Bewegung macht da tatsächlich was aus und
weniger Stress. So, jetzt gucken wir das mal fertig. Allerkrass ist in meinen Augen,
sie erkennt das durchschnittliche Gefäßalter, was ein super Indikator für Herz-Kreislauf-Gesundheit
ist. Jeden Tag diese umfassenden Daten zu haben, hilft mir beim Sport und der Ernährung
zu sehen, welchen Einfluss was auf meinen Körper hat. Kennt noch einer diesen Scam,
der irgendwie von ein bisschen Blut abnehmen angeblich alle möglichen Krankheiten erkennen
sollte und wo dann rausgekommen ist, das Ding erkennt random irgendwas, wo dann Leute sich
haben untersuchen lassen. Auf einmal kamen raus, sie haben Krebs und sowas, die überhaupt
keinen Krebs hatten. Das war eines der krassesten Scams überhaupt. Stell dir mal vor, ihr geht
irgendwo in Urlaub und die sagen dann, wir bieten dir übrigens auch an, sich damit
scannen zu lassen und dann scannt dich das Gerät und sagt, du hast Krebs. Da ist der
Urlaub erstmal im Arsch, oder? Das ist, glaube ich, das beschissenste, was dir passieren
kann, Mann. Du kommst ja danach drauf, dass es nicht stimmt, wenn du dich richtig untersuchen
lässt, aber du bist erstmal schon geschockt. Also richtig hardcore Scam war das.
Das ist voll kompatibel. So was ist nice. Drucksensor fürs Bett.
Den anderen Withings Produkten. Ebenfalls neu vorgestellt wurde neulich eine halb so
teure Alternative, die BodyComp. Sie verzichtet zwar auf das EKG und die segmentielle Muskel-
bzw. Fettverteilung, aber sie kann auch das Gefäßalter messen. Ich bin ein aufrichtiger
Fan der Withings Produkte und deswegen freue ich mich sehr, dass sie mich bei diesem Video
mit Gewicht über Bluetooth und vielleicht, wenn man es unbedingt noch will, Körperfettanteil
vollkommen aus. Der Rest habe ich eh so meine Zweifel, wie aussagekräftig das ist.
Die Frage ist halt, geht das offline? Moment, Moment. Withings, Scale, Home Assistant,
nur über Cloud-Anbindung. Nur über Cloud-Anbindung. Das ist ein Dreck, Mann.
Keh mir schonmal nicht ins Haus. Das ist cool, das gefällt mir. Das ist cool.
Das ist cool, das gefällt mir. Einfach nur nette Spielerei. Ich meine, dass man natürlich
das Zimmer dunkel machen muss, ist auch schon ziemlich sinnlos.
Und dann steht man auch schon vorm Sofa. Es ist immer noch dasselbe. Klar, größer
wäre cool, aber hier ist einfach nicht mehr Platz. Ich finde es bequem und es passen zwei
bis drei Leute drauf. Davor ist das TV-Setup, bestehend aus einem 77 Zoll LG G1 OLED. Er
ist super flach und schön hell. Darunter ist ein TV-Regal von Mate, in dem die Konsolen
und einige Blu-rays verstaut sind. Das Highlight sind sicher die Lautsprecher links und rechts.
Der Devialet Phantom. Jedes Mal, wenn ich die PS5 sehe, den brauche ich dann denken muss.
Das Ding sieht aus wie... Hat jemand Wally geguckt? Irgendwie hält mich das Ding unglaublich
an Eva oder... Wie heißt denn die im Original? Ja, Eva glaube ich. Eve. Das Ding sieht unglaublich
an Eve aus Wally. Also gewisse Ähnlichkeit hat es doch.
Das Highlight sind sicher die Lautsprecher links und rechts. Der Devialet Phantom Gold
sieht aus wie Alien-Technik und der Klang ist auch nicht... Was ist das? Lautsprecher?
...von dieser Welt. Ich mochte meine TV-Software nie super gerne, deswegen habe ich mir ein
Chromecast 4K gekauft. Die Software da ist viel schöner und schneller. Außerdem ist
die Fernbedienung so schön und ergonomisch wie keine zweite. In dieser Wohnung sind relativ
viele Pflanzen, aber weder meine Freundin noch ich haben einen grünen Daumen. Das heißt,
wir kämpfen entweder die ganze Zeit gegen... Turbo Dead End, ich wollte es nicht sagen.
Genau das habe ich mir auch gedacht. Genau das habe ich mir auch gedacht. Kann ich aber
nicht sagen, weil ich habe es nicht ausprobiert und ich habe auch keine Tests zugelesen. Trauermücken
oder ausgetrocknete Pflanzen und bis ich nicht eine Palme am Leben halten kann, will ich
mir auch kein Haustier anschaffen, obwohl ich mir kaum etwas mehr wünsche. Die Küche,
der Essbereich und das Kaffeesetup bilden die zweite Hälfte des offenen Wohnzimmers.
Neu ist dieser erstaunlich wertig aussehende Schrank von Ikea. Auch den haben wir selbst
angemalt, damit er ins restliche Farbkonzept der Wohnung passt. Die Küche hatte auf...
Das siehst du mal. Ich habe mir... Seriously. Ich habe mir nie über das Farbkonzept hier
Gedanken gemacht, aber... Als Designer, Apple Fan, muss man das wahrscheinlich. Es hat
was. Ich muss echt sagen, also ich finde das nicht... Ich finde das echt hübsch.
Ich finde das... Also gerade so mit der Beleuchtung finde ich das wirklich hübsch,
was sie da gemacht haben. Inzwischen habe ich vielleicht auch den ein oder anderen Kaffee zu
viel. Das einzige richtige Küchengerät ist nach wie vor der Thermomix TM6 und der kann ja
auch eigentlich alles. Meine Kaffeemaschine ist eine babyblaue Lama Socolinea Mini mit...
Was?
Weißt du, wo mein Playbutton liegt? Ich glaube, mein Playbutton liegt irgendwo im Schrank
unter... Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, wo liegt mein Playbutton? Ich glaube irgendwo im Schrank
unter ganz vielen Zetteln und so. Ist nun ein Homeoffice und der gigantische Kleiderschrank
von meiner Freundin. Und ihr erfasst es ganz richtig. Ja, auch den haben wir selbst angemalt.
Auf der gegenüberliegenden Seite ist ein höhenverstellbarer Schreibtisch und darauf
mein kleiner Drucker, den ich in meinem Homeoffice Gadget Video... Das sind so typisch Apple User.
Keine zusätzliche Tastatur, keine Maus und sowas. Ich könnte so nicht arbeiten, aber
Apple Leute mögen das. Ich könnte so wirklich nicht arbeiten. Also mal ganz davon absehen,
ich hätte viel zu wenig Platz, um Zeug abzulegen auf dem Schreibtisch. Aber gut, ich brauche
auch einen Desktop-Rechner. Ich brauche auch einen Desktop-Rechner. Aber zumindest, wenn
es ein Notebook ist, ist ein Notebook mit Maus und extra Tastatur dran. Aber dafür sieht es
stylisch aus. Das ist richtig. Wie ich schon mal genauer gezeigt habe. Ich glaube, also
keine Ahnung, ich rate jetzt einfach mal. Ich rate jetzt einfach mal, ja. Angenommen
seine Freundin ist genauso drauf, was Design und diese Clean-Look-Geschichte angeht. Wenn
der mitten ins Wohnzimmer eine Fritz-Bock stellen würde, wo man ein Kabel zur Wand
laufen sieht, das wäre wahrscheinlich schon ein kompletter Weltuntergang. Ich meine,
das ist vielleicht ganz praktisch an der Stelle, weil der Internetanschluss da aus der Wand
kommt, aber das geht nicht. Da würde wahrscheinlich eher für 1.000 Euro nochmal eine Leerrohr
gezogen, dass man dieses Kabel nicht mehr sehen muss. Oder die Fritz-Box wird angemalt.
Oder die Fritz-Box wird angemalt, dass sie ins Farbkonzept passt. Kann auch sein. Matrix,
da gehe ich schon für den Zapf. Hat jeder so seine Präferenzen? Unter dem Tisch. Letztendlich
mit Absaugstation. Sehr gut, sehr gut, sehr gut. Letztendlich muss jeder seine Wohnung
machen, wie er will, ja. Also farblich hat das durchaus was. Farblich, finde ich, haben
sie es sehr schön gemacht. Steht ein Roborock S7 Max-V. Jawoll. Die Reinigungsstation von
dem ist zwar unendlich praktisch, aber echt nicht schön anzusehen und auch nicht gerade
klein. Da sieht man der Unterschied von mir zum 0815 Apple-User. Keine Ahnung, zum Apple-User.
Da wäre die Optik, diese Absaugstation vollkommen scheißegal. Was mir viel mehr auf den Keks
gehen würde, ist, dass die beim S7, wenn man Wasser verwendet, dass das so versifft mit
der Zeit, sodass das da anfängt zu stinken und sowas. Also der Grund würde ich es wahrscheinlich
nicht mit Wasser benutzen zusammen. Praktisch, aber echt nicht schön anzusehen und auch nicht
gerade klein. Deswegen habe ich sie so gut es ging versteckt, ohne den Roboter unnötig
einzuschränken. Siehste, und das Problem dabei ist jetzt wieder, jetzt kannst du die Station
nicht ausleeren, weil er sie versteckt hat. Dafür sieht es schöner aus. Also ist halt
die Frage, was ist einem wichtiger, Optik und Design oder praktische Usability? In dem
Fall würde ich sagen, an vielen Stellen Design ist eindeutig wichtiger als Usability. Er
saugt und wischt jeden Tag zuverlässig die Wohnung. Das Zimmer ist jetzt also eine wilde
Mischung aus Abstellraum, Gästezimmer, Kleiderschrank und Homeoffice. Alle Smart Home Produkte steuern
ich über den... Ich meine, es sieht schon sehr clean und schick aus. Google Home Speaker.
Ich hatte vor einiger Zeit ausschließlich HomePods, aber Siri hat mich zu oft falsch
verstanden und redet auch irgendwie zu viel. Jetzt ist es zwar auch nicht perfekt, aber
besser. Ich mag die Google Nest Hubs extrem gerne. Also weder Smart Speaker noch Nest kommt
mir jemals ins Haus, da sie mit dem Display, Wetterinfos und andere Dinge anzeigen können.
Unser Schlafzimmer hat die krasseste Veränderung durchgemacht. Die eine Wand ist blau-grau,
die andere ist rosa und die Vorhänge halb-halb. Der Kalt-Warm-Kontrast, der dadurch entstanden
ist, ist super gemütlich. Gerade abends mit den Lichterketten und dem Globus.
Ist dieses Bild geblurrt oder ist das standardmäßig geblurrt?
Ami, hatte das für uns geblurrt oder ist das an der Wand schon geblurrt?
Ebenso verändernden Tipp, den ich jedem mitgeben kann, ist eine Bettdecke in Übergröße.
Bei IKEA gibt es so 2,20m auf 2,40m Dinger und es ist ein ungeahnter Luxus für Menschen
meiner Körpergröße, dass ich mich nicht mehr entscheiden muss, ob jetzt meine Füße
rausgucken oder meine Schulter, weil alles drunter passt.
Meine Smartwatch steht an der Dyson Nachttischlampe, mein Smartphone auf der Konsole. Dort packe
ich auch meine Kopfhörer und andere Gadgets an den Strom.
Meine Parfüllsammlung ist in letzter Zeit gewachsen. Gestartet habe ich vor Jahren mit Barfl...
Mit dem Regal so an der Wand hätte ich permanent Angst, dass ich irgendwas runterschmeiße.
... von Scotch und Soda, aber dann habe ich mich schnell, auch wegen dem Namen, aber vor
allem wegen dem Geruch, für Kilian Paris dürfte entschieden.
Ich liebe einfach dieses etwas verrücktere Angelshare und das total intensive Taste of
Heaven.
Für den Sommer habe ich dann ein eher frisches Piagium 7.2.
Diese Wohnung hier hat sehr viel Technik und auch sehr viel Einfluss durch Technikprodukte.
Zum Beispiel das rosa und blau, das habe ich zum ersten Mal bei Technikprodukten gesehen.
Okay, also super krass, Hightech würde ich jetzt nicht sagen. Er hat ein paar coole
Sachen. Also der Fernseh ist auf jeden Fall extrem nice.
Den Fernseh würde ich mir auch so eins zu eins geben, wenn ich nicht schon dann hätte.
Der ist nice, die Küche ist relativ klein, der Rest, also farblich muss ich sagen, haben
sie das wirklich schön gemacht. Es wäre nicht so wirklich mein Fall, wie gesagt.
Bei mir ist eigentlich fast alles an der Stelle dort, nicht weil es gut aussieht, sondern
weil es praktisch ist und ich würde nicht sagen, dass meine Wohnung bzw. hier im Haus,
das auch nur ansatzweise so durchdesigned aussieht, ganz im Gegenteil.
Bei mir im Bad steht mittendrin einfach so ein Wäschekorb.
Und warum steht denn Wäschekorb bei mir im Bad? Aus zwei Gründen, weil da nicht Wäsche
drin ist, sondern Klopapier. Wenn man nämlich auf dem Klo sitzt und hat
gerade kein Klopapier mehr, kann man den Wäschekorb aufmachen und Klopapier rausholen und ich
kann da drauf Tablets und mein Smartphone ablegen und ich kann den Wäschekorb dorthin
stellen, wo ich es brauche. Also entweder stelle ich den Wäschekorb
vor dem Klo, also das Wäschekorb, der ist ein bisschen höher, das ist kein flacher,
sondern geht ein bisschen hoch. Entweder stelle ich den Wäschekorb vor das
Klo, dann kann ich das Handy und Tablet ablegen, wenn ich gerade auf dem Klo sitze.
Ich kann es rüber stellen über die Dusche, da kann ich, wenn ich mich morgens anziehe
und irgendwas gucken will, kann ich das Handy drauflegen, ich kann es in die Mitte irgendwie
entschieben, wenn ich ein bisschen Musik anmachen will, wenn ich duschen gehe.
Es ist nicht ordentlich bei mir aus diesem Gesichtspunkt, überhaupt nicht.
Aber ich habe die Sachen halt eher, weil sie praktisch sind und ich würde beispielsweise
auch nicht, ich würde sein Handy mit aufs Klo nehmen, so gut wie jeder und wenn ich
es nicht dabei habe, dann habe ich extra noch ein Tablet standardmäßig auf dem Klo liegen,
kiffgeneig für den Sub und ich würde beispielsweise auch nicht die Reinigungsstation von dem Staubsaugerroboter
so unter Tisch stellen, dass man nicht drankommt. Aber es ist halt immer die Frage, will man
eher so diesen cleanen Look und so dieses Katalogfeeling von der Wohnung haben oder
stört einen das nicht weiter und man will es einfach möglichst praktisch und ohne extra
Handgriffe haben.
Chat, wir machen jetzt eine Umfrage. Wann ist die Umfrage? Wer sein Handy mit aufs Klo
nimmt? Handy mit aufs Klo, Fragezeichen. Ja, nein. Duration, auf geht's, bin mal gespannt.
Also ich würde ja behaupten, so gut wie jeder nimmt sein Handy mit aufs Klo. Aber kann ja
sein, dass wir falsch liegen. Die Espressomaschine kostet 5000 Euro, wer hat, der hat. Manch
einer kauft sich ein 5000 Euro PC, manch einer kauft 5000 Euro Espressomaschine. Also früher,
als ich noch kein Smartphone hatte, habe ich immer CT gelesen auf dem Klo. Ich habe letztens
mal eine CT Sammlung weggeschmissen. Ich hatte CTs, CT-Magazine seit, frag mich nicht, 2001
oder so, schon ganz, ganz lange. Und ich habe letztens quasi 20 Jahre CT-Magazine weggeschmissen.
Da war komplett, komplettes Regal voll. Jetzt habe ich wieder massig Platz. Nee, nee, weder
noch. Ich werde die CT abbestellen, ich lese sie so gut wie nicht mehr. Okay, also die meisten
Leute nehmen ihr Handy mit aufs Klo. Die meisten Leute nehmen ihr Handy mit aufs Klo. Du bist
aber, also du warst eh nicht alleine, das wusste ich, weil irgendjemand vorher schon geschrieben
hat, er nimmt kein Handy mit. Aber, ja. Also ich würde sagen, ich hätte es sogar fast
noch ein bisschen eindeutiger erwartet. Ich hätte es eher so auf 90, 10 getippt vielleicht.
Aber es deckt sich so mit ungefähr dem, was ich meine. Okay. Also, ja. Jeder wie er. Kritisch,
wir haben den Aldi Gaming PC aus der Werbung gekauft. Warum ist das kritisch? Das ist bestimmt
G-Bait das Video wieder. Das ist so massive G-Bait wieder. Das sieht ein bisschen aus.
Nee, das ist Cyberpunk. Ja, das ist Cyberpunk. Ich wollte gerade sagen, ich wollte gerade
sagen, das BIOS sieht etwas aus wie das Cyberpunk Menü, aber es war das Cyberpunk Menü. Nicht
LX, EX. Aber das ist ein gutes Video. Das hatte ich auch in meiner später Guckliste.
So, was haben wir denn hier sonst noch zu bieten? Wir haben Fireship, Windows-Dossens-Doesn't-Suck,
Microsoft-Title, das ist G-Bait-Titel, Alter. Obvision pro Verkauf der Küche, das Gehalt
als Küchenplaner in München. Okay, in München muss der Dude allein schon mal das Doppelte
verdienen von allen anderen, weil München so ultra teuer ist. 5 Next-Cloud-Updates,
that will make you ditch Google and Apple. Ja, alles klar. Next-Cloud, natürlich, natürlich.
Also wenn... Moment, ich muss ein bisschen lauter machen. Also wenn die Leute irgendwas
nicht dazu verleitet, Apple und Google zu ditchen, dann dürfte es Next-Cloud sein.
Next-Cloud hat ein paar ganz nice Funktionen, die man durchaus gebrauchen kann. 80% davon
ist allerdings leider angefangener, aber nie fertiggemachter, halbfertiger Mist. Okay,
wir schauen uns das... Okay, gucken wir uns mal an, was der Küchenplaner in München
verdient. Die Arbeit hat bei mir schon sehr hoch. Arbeitest du nun in einer größeren
oder einer eher kleinen Firma? Ehrlich gesagt, ich arbeite in einer relativ... Naja, ich
arbeite in einer... mittel bis großen Firma, weil wie das so ist, bankentechnisch und
IT, bin ich natürlich nicht direkt bei der Bank angestellt, sondern bei so einer extra
Firma, die nur für IT, für die Bank macht. Und das ist dann halt aus rechtlichen Gründen
und aus wirtschaftlichen und steuerlichen Gründen so gemacht. Also ich würde sagen,
das ist eine mittel bis große Firma, wo ich aktuell arbeite. Wenn man natürlich die
gesamte Bank nimmt, ist es groß. Und ich wechsle jetzt zu einem Arbeitgeber, der ist noch größer.
Also ich wechsle von einem mittel bis großen zu einem ziemlich großen. Ja, genau. Das
fängt schon an, dass die Apps zum größten Teil nix taugen. Also was macht der Küchenplaner
in München auf jetzt? Allein schon dadurch, dass man den ganzen Wachentag ja irgendwie
dann doch bei der Arbeit ist. Also dieses Jahr kommen noch 21.000 Euro oben drauf als Bonus.
Hallo, ich bin Felix, ich bin 30 Jahre alt und bin Küchenplaner in München. Denn nur
mit Felix los. Ich bin eigentlich eher durch Zufall in die Küche geraten. Schon wieder
die Style der hipster, einer nach dem anderen. Als ich nach München gezogen bin, war es
dann ein Zufall, dass ich hier im Laden vorbeigegangen bin und draußen stand ein Aushang. Wir suchen
jemanden für einen Empfang, der unsere Kunden Kaffee anbietet und so weiter und so fort.
Ich bin dann hier reingelaufen und bin dann mit dem Studioleiter hier in Kontakt gekommen
und dann haben wir uns anderthalb Stunden oder so über Küche, Architektur, Interior unterhalten
und am Ende war für mich irgendwie klar, hey, das will ich irgendwie machen, obwohl
ich das vorher gar nicht auf den Schirm hatte. Bin dann sofort nach Hause, habe eine Bewerbung
als Küchenplaner geschrieben. Da sieht man aber schon mal, man kann durchaus mit persönlichem
Kontakt oder gutem, sich gut verkaufen, kann man tatsächlich punkten, ja. Dann hat mich
der Studioleiter angerufen und meinte, du hast dich jetzt als Küchenplaner beworben,
willst du nicht eigentlich unten am Empfang Kaffee machen? Naja, und dann kam eins zum
anderen und seitdem bin ich hier seit viereinhalb Jahren. Lieber Küchenplaner. Wir als Küchenplaner
betreuen quasi Küchenprojekte von A bis Z und im Grunde ist es ja unsere Aufgabe. Wo
ist denn, das ist aber kein Pullover mit Reiter, das stimmt auch schon irgendwas nicht. Haben
wir nicht letztens in einem Video gelernt, der Reiter muss immer mit? Als Küchenplaner
all diese Gedanken, die irgendwie lose im Kopf des Kunden sind, irgendwie perfekt sozusagen
in die Küche reinzubringen.
Die zwei kamen, glaube ich, vor einem Jahr das erste Mal hierher, als es quasi damit
losging oder als sie sich gesagt haben, okay, wir wollen umbauen in ihrem Haus und seitdem
treffen wir uns in zwei Monatsabständen, sage ich immer wieder und dann, ich weiß nicht,
mal war es am Anfang eine dunkle Küche, jetzt, dann war es zwischendurch hell, jetzt sind
wir heute wieder eher bei dunkel. Boah, so, das ist der Grund, warum ich sowas nie machen
könnte. Ich will Zustände kriegen, wenn mir die Leute erzählen, ich will eine helle Küche
und ich plane eine helle Küche und dann kommen sie und sagen, ah, die Küche ist mir eigentlich
zu hell, ich will jetzt eine dunkle Küche. Dann würde ich sagen, aber habt ihr sie noch
alle und dann würde ich wahrscheinlich sagen, und dann würden sie mich rausschmeißen.
Also die grobe Planung steht im Grunde schon und jetzt haben wir uns letzten Termin für,
ich sag mal, Farbe, Hersteller schon so mehr oder weniger festgelegt.
Wie lang zum Teufel planen die denn so eine Küche?
Ich hab jetzt mal die Küche ein bisschen so angepasst, nochmal mit der Griffmulde auch,
können wir uns nochmal kurz so anschauen. Also hier passiert ja relativ viel, weil wir
ja hier durch das offene Park eventuell auch einen Cut haben und hier auf der Seite wären
es ja einfach nur Schränke einander gewesen. Das Ding finde ich es auch ganz schön, wenn
man da noch ein bisschen Tiefe reinbringt tatsächlich und nochmal zwei.
Wie guckst du so, als hättest du überhaupt keinen Bock, Alter.
Der hat die gerade Griffmulden da einplant. Wenn der Kunde jetzt oft auch gar nicht genau
weiß, was er eigentlich ausgeben will und sich eher so ein bisschen inspirieren lassen
will, dann gehen wir oft mit dem Kunden so ein bisschen durch und versuchen so transparent
wie möglich zu sagen, okay, wenn wir jetzt sagen, wir wollen den Hersteller, der von innen
vielleicht alles foniert, alles Holz, Holzauszüge und so weiter, wer da vielleicht teurer.
Wenn der Kunde sagt, innen ist eben nicht so wichtig, kann man aber auch sagen, man macht
es innen ein bisschen einfacher und von außen soll es schön aussehen, dann versuchen wir
halt. Also eins muss ich sagen, ich bin mir gar
nicht sicher mehr, wo wir die Küche gekauft haben. Ich weiß nur noch der Typ, der da
war, um die Küche zu bauen. Also da muss ich sagen, der hat es echt drauf gehabt.
Also irgendwann 2013 oder so war das, Küche gekauft und dann kam dann so ein Typ zum Einbauen.
Der hat an einem Tag, der hat irgendwie acht Stunden oder so die Küche gebaut. Ein Typ,
ein Typ, acht Stunden, da war die Küche fertig. Der ging ab, Alter, sag ich euch. Ein Typ
kam da, richtiger Giga-Chat. Der sah gar nicht so Giga-Chat mäßig aus,
der sah eher dünn und ja gut, der ist halt den ganzen Tag am flitzen. Der ist morgens
angerückt, ich glaube um halb acht oder so, der war übelst in der Früh da und hat dann
acht Stunden durchgeschafft, dann war die Küche fertig.
Gut, man muss sagen, die Geräte und sowas musste er nicht alle irgendwie reintragen und
so. Also den Herd und die Hülmaschine und so, das hatten wir vorher alle schon. Der
musste wirklich nur die Küche bauen, das Holz, sowas. Aber das war wirklich, das war
wirklich, also muss ich sagen, das in einem Tag von quasi Geräte stehen sinnlos rum
zu fertiger Küche wirklich nicht schlecht.
Als Küchenplaner einen Eindruck oder den Kunden kennenzulernen und kennenzulernen, was dem
Kunden wichtig ist und versuchen das entsprechend einzuplanen.
Ja und ich würde sagen, der Felix zeigt auch viel Geduld.
Also mir wäre in einer Küche wichtig, bzw. ich kann euch sagen, was in meiner Küche
wichtig war, dass der Kram einfach funktioniert, dass ich genug Platz habe und dass ich nicht
laufen irgendwo an Ecke oder irgendwas umschieben muss oder irgendwas umstellen muss, wenn ich
was machen will. Also ich will keine Designerküche, die nur optisch schön aussieht, das muss
funktionieren. Ich will den Schrank aufroppen können, wenn es schwer ist. Warnen genommen,
ich bin am Rechner und ich muss mich beeilen, was weiß ich, entweder spiele ich MMOs, Gruppe
am Start oder ich streame irgendwas, ich muss schnell runterflitzen und immer was zu trinken
holen. Ich flitze die Treppe runter, robb den Schrank auf, hol ein Glas raus, hau den
Schrank eben raus, rennen wir dazu und gut ist, das muss funktionieren, ohne dass ich
den Schrank kaputt mache, ohne dass ich irgendwo dagegen renne, ohne dass mir die Hälfte aus
dem Regal im Schrank entgegenfällt. Das muss einfach funktionieren. Das ist mir bei ganz
vielen Sachen wichtig und ich gebe im Zweifelsfall dafür auch ein bisschen mehr Geld aus, wenn
du sagst, der Kram muss robust sein und der Kram muss funktionieren. Die Optik ist auch
nicht ganz unwichtig, aber es muss stabil sein und funktionieren. Das ist genauso wie
wenn ich irgendwelche, vom Sofa bis zum Schreibt. Der Stuhl hier, ohne Scheiße, der Stuhl ist
das beste Beispiel für. Der Stuhl ist eigentlich, die meisten Leute würden sagen, Max bist
du bescheuert, warum kaufst du dir so einen teuren Stuhl? Und das ist kein super Designerstuhl
oder sowas. Wisst ihr, warum ich den Stuhl hier habe? Erstens, weil ich da stundenlang
am Tag davor sitze und zweitens, weil ich nicht gerne gezwungenermaßen sanft mit den
Werkzeugen umgehen möchte. Also sprich, ich will jetzt nicht irgendwas haben, was gut
aussieht, wo ich dann aber super vorsichtig sein muss, dass es nicht kaputt geht. Also
wenn ich einen Stuhl habe, dann will ich quasi aus dem Stehen mich da drauf platschen lassen,
ohne dass das Ding kaputt geht. Dabei ist mir ja mein DX Racer Stuhl kaputt gegangen, beim
zu schnell und zu stark beanspruchten. Also, wenn ich vor dem Stuhl stehe, wenn ich vor
dem Stuhl stehe, ich meine ihr hört es jetzt ja, ich mache es jetzt einfach mal, ich stelle
mich vor den Stuhl, jetzt mache ich Wupp, zack und dann wird sich drauf gesetzt, das
muss das Ding abkönnen, ohne dass die Federung kaputt geht, ohne dass die Armlehne abbricht,
ohne dass es sich verbiegt oder sonst was. Das Ding muss einfach halten. Deswegen habe
ich auch einen Stuhl, der glaube ich aushält bis 250 Kilo. Ich meine aktuell wiege ich
91,5. Aber, so mit Beschleunigung und Bremsen, wisst ihr ja, da wiegst du kurzzeitig auch
mal deutlich mehr. Und er hält halt was aus. Das Ding ist kein wahnsinnig schöner Designer
Stuhl, aber es ist super stabil und hält seit über 10 Jahren wie neu. Also ich habe
einen, kann ich euch zeigen, Dedus Mister 24. Ein Swiffle Chair, nee so ein Ding. Der 24
Stunden Stuhl für lange Arbeitseinsätze. Gaming Stuhl zackt. Das ist kein super krasser
Designer Stuhl, aber das Ding ist stabil. Das hält aus bis 250 Kilo, glaube ich. Technische
Daten. Okay, okay. 200 Kilo, 200 Kilo, 200 Kilo. Du kannst relativ einfach sogar Sachen
austauschen, wenn du willst. Und was ich persönlich mag und was ich auch so, also in einem anderen
Stuhl, also keinen anderen Stuhl mehr kaufen würde, der es nicht hat. Man kann die Armlehnen
verstellen. Wo runter, links, rechts und vorne, hinten. Also man kann die quasi dreidimensional
verstellen, die Armlehnen. Das ist enorm praktisch, weil ich habe beispielsweise gerne den, also
ich habe das genau gerne exakt auf der Höhe, dass es gerade noch so unter den Tisch passt,
weil ansonsten ist einfach der Winkel zu hoch für Armlehne und Maus und sonst was. Und
ich habe gerne die rechte Armlehne ein bisschen vor der linken Armlehne, weil ich ein bisschen
nach links gedreht sitze, dass ich beide Bildschirme besser sehe. Also ich gerade vor dem rechten
sitze und so ein bisschen den Kopf zum linken drehen muss. Ich sitze so 10 Grad oder so
nach links immer und deswegen ist dann die Armlehne rechts bündig mit dem Tisch, wenn
ich das ein bisschen vorgestellt habe und links kann ich wunderbar an die Tastatur
von da. Also das ist das, was mir wichtig ist. Das muss ergonomisch sein beim Arbeiten,
das muss einfach funktionieren und stabil sein. Du kannst einstellen, wie schwerfällig
es nach hinten und nach vorne geht. Man kann das ganz feststellen. Du kannst hier unten
einstellen, wie der Abstand zwischen Lehne und Sitzkissen ist. Sitzkiste kannst du neigen
und nach vorne stellen. Du kannst dazu alles umstellen, was du brauchst. Die Nackenstütze
gibt es in verschiedenen Ausführungen. Kipp, ich habe die hier. Ich habe die hier ehrlich
gesagt total unsinnig, hätte ich gar nicht gebraucht. Aber gut, die hier wäre wahrscheinlich
besser gewesen. Hier sieht man nämlich auch, wie man den Krampf erstellen kann. Und du
schwitzt nicht am Rücken mit diesem Polster. Das ist wirklich gut gemacht, du schwitzt
nicht. Beine werden auch mit der Zeit nicht taub oder so. Es gibt ja Stühle, wenn die
gar zu harte und zu Kanten haben, dass du die ein bisschen so ganz lange in einer Position
setzt, da wird das Blut ein bisschen abgedrückt. Da hast du alles nicht. Alles wunderbar. Das
Ding ist auch natürlich höhenverstellbar und das Ding ist wirklich stabil. Ja, das
ist natürlich eines der Probleme an so einem Stuhl. Der ist halt ein bisschen teurer neu.
Also wenn man den in der Custom-Ausstattung haben möchte, wie man ihn will, mit der Farbe
wie man will und dem Polster wie man will, muss man wahrscheinlich schon so 1400, 1500
Euro rechnen für den Stuhl. Das ist natürlich schon ein bisschen was. Aber auf der anderen
Seite, ich meine, wenn man den jeden Tag mehrere Stunden verwendet und das Ding nach 10 Jahren
immer noch absolut top ist, hat sich das schon wieder ausgezahlt. Das Ding ist, das ist
wie ein Panzer. Ja, ist es. Das ist wirklich stabil. Also du hast ja hier neben auch allein
schon, das ist ja alles richtig massives und starkes Metall hier. Also auch die Armlehnen,
das ist richtig massiv, massives Stahl oder so. Also da ist nichts, da machst du nichts
kaputt. Ich habe mich da schon so drauf gehauen auf den Stuhl, quasi aus dem Laufen mehr
oder weniger drauf gesprungen. Ich habe da sogar schon mehrfach drauf gestanden. Frag
mich nicht warum. Ich habe da schon mehrfach drauf gestanden. Ich weiß, man soll das auf
einem Stuhl mit Rollen eigentlich nicht machen, aber manchmal hast du halt nichts anderes
da. Das ist überhaupt kein Ding. Das hält das alles aus. Also das ist wirklich ein Stuhl,
den kann ich nur wärmstens empfehlen. Das ist der beste, wirklich mit Abstand der beste
Bürostuhl, den ich kenne. Ich würde mir auch keinen irgendwie Designer Bürostuhl oder
sonst was kaufen. Das Ding gewinnt bestimmt jetzt keinen Apple Designer Award oder sowas,
aber es ist stabil as fuck unbequem. So muss das sein. Wie läuft es mit dem Abnehmen? Hat
es nicht mehr so viel getan. Das ist jetzt irgendwie 91,5, 91,2 irgendwie so in dem Dreh.
Aber dieses Jahr unter 90, easy, easy. Wenn es ein bisschen wärmer ist, kann ich wieder
ein bisschen mehr laufen draußen. Aktuell ist es kacke. Ich laufe zwar immer noch so
eine Stunde, eineinhalb Stunden am Tag, allerdings mache ich jetzt eher ein bisschen weniger
Stunde, maximal eineinhalb Stunden. Ansonsten war ich ja teilweise zwei Stunden unterwegs,
meistens auch hier in der Nähe irgendwie schnell um die Ecke gelaufen. Ab März oder
so, wenn es wieder wärmer wird, kann ich dann auch wieder in die Berge fahren. Berge,
bei uns in der Nähe, da lachen sich die Schweizer kaputt, wenn ich sage, das sind Berge. Da
laufe ich eh lieber. Es macht halt einfach einen Unterschied, ob man berghoch, bergunter
läuft oder nur geradeaus. Das ist halt doch ein bisschen anstrengender und vor allem
abwechslungsreicher. So, also was macht der Küchenverkäufer? Ja, doch nicht so sehr
entscheidungsfreudig. Also ob jetzt eine dunkle oder eine helle Front nehmen oder dunkle.
Eine dunkle oder helle Front, das dürfte eines der Basic-Entscheidungen schlechthin sein,
man. Ich mein, ob die Küche hell oder dunkel ist, das ist doch eines der ersten Dinge,
was man sich so vorstellt, oder? Ich sag doch auch nicht, ah, ich brauche eine, ich kaufe
eine Playstation, ah nee, jetzt doch eine Xbox, vielleicht doch eine Switch. Also, so
ein paar kunstsätzliche Sachen, man. Ich bin der Helmstein und da hilft er uns schon
auch bei der Auswahl, also das ist auf jeden Fall sehr hilfreich. Wenn du Provision kriegst,
hilft er euch bei allem. Also, danke und bis zum nächsten Mal. Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ordentlich. Ich hab keine Ahnung mehr, was die Küche unten gekostet hat, aber definitiv
keine 80k. Ja, wir sind jetzt verabredet mit dem Bauherrn und dem Architekten und sprechen
nochmal ein paar Sachen durch. Ja, es ist halt, also es ist alles jetzt schon fertig bestellt,
also auch der Stein ist jetzt schon fertig bestellt. Normalerweise machen wir erst immer
Küchenmontage, dann kommt Steinmetz zum Aufmaß. Wir haben es aber jetzt so gemacht, auch wegen
der Lieferzeit, damit wir vor Weihnachten die Küche fertig haben, dass die Platten schon
fertig sind. Das heißt, wir müssen alles sehr, sehr passgenau ohne große Puffer einplanen,
damit es nachher passt. Hallo, grüß dich. Ja, jetzt in dem Fall sind es, es ist jetzt
auch ein spannender Moment natürlich immer, weil bei einer Steinplatte immer viel passieren
kann. Ich meine, es müssen zwei, drei Leute allein hochtragen, die schwer, die spärig,
die Stegbreiten sind relativ eng, sodass da auch irgendwas theoretisch natürlich immer
mal passieren, brechen oder was auch immer kann. Was nicht passt, ist eigentlich noch
schlimmer, weil dann bin ich ja quasi schuld als Küchenplaner. Hatte ich bis jetzt zum
Glück noch nicht, aber klar, wenn was nicht passen sollte, dann muss man halt schnell
sich um eine andere Lösung kümmern. Aber jetzt in dem Fall bin ich eigentlich optimistisch,
dass es genauso passt, wie wir uns das vorstellen. Moment, hochkant? Also, das muss doch hingelegt
werden. Da kommt die Spüle rein, oder? Würde ich mal vermuten. Also, hier kommt die, ne,
da sind mehrere. Hier ist ein Loch. Hier kommt das Waschbecken rein, oder? Oder die Herdplatte.
Ja, das kann auch sein. Wahrscheinlich die Herdplatte. Wahrscheinlich die Herdplatte.
Ja, hier kannst du Zeug schnüppeln und da kommt dann der Herd hin. Waschbecken ist
wahrscheinlich auf der anderen Seite. Ah, wir sehen es gleich. Oh, oh, oh, oh, anzeige
ist raus. Ah, ne, passt. Passt doch. Passt. Ja, würde ich sagen, soweit ganz gut. Also
hat alles soweit ganz gut gepasst, bis auf einen Teil, aber das sollten wir eigentlich
auch schnell hinbekommen. Also grundsätzlich der ganze Grundaufbau, die ganzen Platten
passen. Und es sieht soweit erstmal ganz gut aus. Also man kann die Ziegküche jetzt
tatsächlich mal so ein bisschen vorstellen. Gut geplant. Gut geplant. Und? Und super montiert.
Naja, das ist wahrscheinlich gar nicht so, oder? Bisschen wenig Platz, oder? Kommt
mir das nur so vor. Viel Platz ist da nett. Mein Stuhl, dedus mister 24. Geht doch, das
geht doch klar. Zwölf mal zwölf. Ist immer die Frage mal zwölf oder mal 14? Mal zwölf,
naja. Vor allem so viel Kundenkontakt, da hätte ich ja schon mal gar keinen Bock drauf.
Ich verdiene 4580 Euro brutto im Monat. Also dieses Jahr kommen noch mal ungefähr 21.000
Euro brutto obendrauf als Bonus sozusagen. Und das setzt sich jetzt nicht nur aus Verkauf
zusammen. Also wie viel war das jetzt? Ich verdiene 4580 Euro brutto im Monat. Also 4600
mal zwölf. 55.000. Dieses Jahr kommen noch mal ungefähr 21.000 Euro brutto obendrauf
als. Also 72.000. Doch. Ach, Moment. 55.000, nicht 51.000, 55.000. 72.000. Halt mir jetzt
eigentlich ganz sinnvoll zu sein. Ich bin das Video wieder. Also, musst halt auch ordentlich
verkaufen. Wenn du nicht ordentlich verkaufst, dann wird es halt nichts. Also 76.000. Bonus
sozusagen. Und das setzt sich jetzt nicht nur aus Verkauf zusammen, sondern auch aus
Spezialprojekten, die ich dieses Jahr teilweise übernommen habe. Also sie haben dieses Jahr
ein Presseprojekt gehabt, wo ich was ich quasi übernommen habe und ein paar andere kleinere
Themen noch. Also ich komme mit meinem Monatsgehalt eigentlich sehr gut hin. 76.000, das denke
ich dafür wirklich in Ordnung. Aber ja auch keinen besonderen Lifestar, sage ich mal.
Klar, wir wohnen jetzt in München in der zentralen Lage, aber die Wohnung ist relativ
klein. Wir haben keine Kinder, wir haben kein Auto. Also ich kann von dem Gehalt sehr gut
leben. Ich bin zu Hause. Na? Wie geht's? Gut, und dir? Wunderbar. Gleich zeigt er uns
bestimmt seine Kaffeemaschine. Oh nein. Erstmal in die Küche. Ja. Wir haben uns dann dazu
entschieden, die Küche hier rauszunehmen, die wir jetzt vorher reingebaut hatten. Ich
habe die Küche geplant letztendlich. Als Küchenplaner hast du natürlich deine eigene
Küche geplant. Ich sagte, okay, wir bauen die hier rein. Im Grunde hat meine Freundin
auch an der Planung viel mit zu beigetragen, gerade an den Farben. Also wir haben beim letzten
Tag der möglichen Änderungen haben wir noch von komplett schwarz mit schwarzer Marmplatte
geändert auf Kaschmierfarben. Also wir waren da genauso wie meine Kunden auch, waren wir
da auch bis zum letzten Ende sozusagen nicht ganz sicher, was wir machen wollen und haben
am Ende so. Guck mal, der hat auch die übertriebene Kaffeemaschine wieder am Start. Mit Montage
um die 12.000 Euro bezahlt für die Küche. Ich falle da leider raus. Also wahrscheinlich
würde ich gerne Kaffee trinken, hätte ich mir wahrscheinlich auch eine gescheite Kaffeemaschine
gegönnt. So ich glaube für Kaffeefans ist was. Ich trinke aber eigentlich nie Kaffee.
Ja und Dreh- und Angehtpunkt der Küche ist natürlich unsere Kaffeemaschine, der ich
damals von meinem alten Arbeitgeber, also ich habe, bevor ich Küchen verkauft habe, habe
ich sozusagen auch schon in der Küchenbranche mich bewegt, aber eben Kaffeemaschinen verkauft
und habe da mir sozusagen im Laufe der Zeit irgendwann dann die Maschine anschaffen wollen
bzw. Guck mal, das ist auch schon wieder so ein Kaffee-Feinschmecker. Arbeitgeber mich
dabei auch unterstützt und die begleitet mich jetzt hoffentlich mein Leben lang. Und
ich weiß auch nicht, ob ich die für einen vollen Preis mir so hätte leisten wollen
und können, aber ich habe es noch keinen Tag bereut. Also meiner Erfahrung nach, bei
allen Sachen wo man denkt, oh das hält jetzt lang und das hält ein Leben lang, es hält
meistens kurzer als man denkt. Gerade bei Technik.
Bereut.
Angefangen mit dem Hobby haben wir vor einem Jahr oder so mal angefangen.
Ist das Blender? Leute, ich habe keinen Plan. Was ist das? Was sieht man da?
3D-Renderings eben zu machen, die ein bisschen über diesen Küchenplan hinausgehen und ich
sage mal den Kunden ein bisschen mehr ein Gefühl von der echten Küche vermitteln.
Der Kunde, der bekommt vom Architekten halt immer nur den 2D-Plan und damit er sich das
besser vorstellen kann, genau da setzen wir halt an und bauen den Raum in 3D nach und
es geht im Grunde darum, dass wir das, was der Kunde später bekommt, heute schon, ohne
dass es real existiert, in Fotorealismus darstellen.
So ein gemeinsames Hobby tut dem Ganzen auch irgendwie ganz gut. Es macht uns auch echt
mega Spaß.
Das ist auch schon wieder so eine Wohnung, die aussieht wie irgendwie so ein komisches,
weiß ich, unfertiges Zimmer, Alter. Studio, Studio, trifft es ganz gut, ja. Aber immerhin,
nice, nice Bild. Das ist tatsächlich eines der wenigen Sachen, die ich hier so an Style,
könnte man sagen, in der Wohnung bzw. im Haus habe. Ich habe relativ viele Bilder rumhängen,
so Ölgemälde rumhängen. Aber ansonsten ist bei mir wenig Style.
Spaß.
Ja, so verbringen wir unsere Wochenenden.
Also nicht, dass jetzt einer denkt, ich bin der krasse Kunstsammler oder so, die sind von
meinem Opa. Mein Opa hat relativ viel gemalt und er hat auch ein paar wirklich coole Bilder
und die hängen hier im Haus rum.
Ja, es ist jetzt ungefähr halb 7 und wir haben jetzt noch eine, ich habe jetzt noch
eine Abnahme. Es ist ja oft so, dass die Kunden dann erst nach Feierabend, ich sag mal, richtig
Zeit finden.
Oh, da hätte ich ja so keinen Bock drauf.
Abendtermine, weil, also, wenn man auf der anderen Seite auch die Freiheit hat, dann
mal irgendwie eine längere Mittagspause zu machen oder im Sommer zum Beispiel irgendwie
dann das Wetter mal mittags zu genießen.
Okay, bei 40 bis 50 Stunden relativiert sich das mit dem Geld ja schon wieder ein bisschen.
Da sind ja schon mal zehn Stunden mehr als andere Arbeiten. Und viele arbeiten eh nur
noch 38 Stunden. Dann muss es natürlich auch mehr Kohle sein.
Aber ich meine, das relativiert sich ja schon wieder ein bisschen.
Das sind quasi 20% mehr Arbeitszeit, ich sage jetzt einfach mal so 20-25% mehr Arbeitszeit
von normalen Leuten. Und dementsprechend ist das mit dem Gehalt dann auch nur noch ganz
okay, doch nicht so viel.
Bei 38, 39 Stunden, was auch immer, würde ich sagen top. Aber bei 50 oder 48 oder so,
dann ist es wahrscheinlich ein bisschen wenig Schmerzensgeld.
Aber abends mal zur Baustelle zu fahren, ist es eigentlich ganz schön, wenn man da die
Flexibilität hat.
Kriegt der Urlaubstage Ausgleich? Das ist eine gute Frage, ja. Also sprich, vielleicht
ist dann das, was er im Jahr insgesamt arbeitet, doch, aber das glaube ich nicht, wäre interessant
zu wissen.
Hallo, Herr Füls. Guten Tag, Willem. Kommen Sie rein? Ja, lange nicht gesehen. So, bitteschön.
Treten Sie ein.
Hast du den Eindruck fast schon, als will die ihm was verkaufen gerade? Also die schönsten
Momente sind eigentlich, wenn Sachen funktionieren, wenn Sachen, die man irgendwie plant. Okay,
die hat Platz in ihrer Küche. Das sieht auch schon wieder so studiomäßig aus, aber die
hat Platz in ihrer Küche. Also da kannst du nichts sagen. Das ist mal eine ordentliche
Küche.
Auch hier wieder Steinplatte. Aber hier hast du ordentlich Platz und hinten geht es ja noch
weiter.
Ist das der Herd? Haben die keinen Dunstabzug oder so was? Dann saust du dir hier alles
drum herum ein.
Wenn Sachen funktionieren.
Ja, da kannst du bestimmt irgendeinen Dunstabzug runterziehen. Der fährt aus. Das hier ist
der Abzug. Das funktioniert. Also ich meine, der Wasserdampf geht ja so. Das heißt, der
Sauger muss stark genug sein, dass er das so wieder runter saugt.
Okay.
Wenn Sachen, die man irgendwie plant, dann auch so am Ende bei rauskommen, wie man sich
das vorgestellt hat und wenn dann eben der Kunde das auch wertschätzt und irgendwie
merkt, hey.
Aber jetzt hat man mal, ist das ja eine Rietküche. Wobei, hier hinten ist gar nicht so viel,
wie ich gedacht habe. Aber ich muss sagen, also ist zwar auch ein bisschen hipster mäßig,
aber die gefällt mir wirklich ganz gut.
Vorgestellt hast und wenn dann eben der Kunde das auch wertschätzt und irgendwie merkt,
hey.
Da hat sich jemand wirklich Mühe gemacht, um irgendwie bestimmte Details hinzubekommen.
Dann sind das, würde ich sagen, die glücklichsten Momente, die wir haben.
Ja, der Wasserhahn ist im Rust-Look.
Ich denke mir dann immer, haben die Leute diese Küche wirklich, um darin zu kochen?
Also hier kannst du auf jeden Fall, da ist wirklich genug Platz. Du kannst sogar mit
mehreren Leuten was machen, wenn du willst.
Haben die Leute einfach nur die Küche immer, um cool auszusehen oder kochen die da auch
wirklich drin?
Also ist das, genau, ist die Küche zum Flexen, wenn mal jemand vorbeikommt oder um sie wirklich
zu benutzen?
Also ich bin ganz happy mit meiner schönen Küche.
Cool.
Ja, also ich würde sagen, Küchenplaner sein lohnt sich auf jeden Fall.
Also gerade für solche Momente, wo man irgendwie am Ende in die fertige Küche mit Dekoration
kommt und der Kunde sich schon eingelebt hat, ist irgendwie ein schönes Gefühl und macht
einfach Spaß am Ende zu sehen, was hat funktioniert, was kann man vielleicht beim nächsten Mal
noch ein bisschen besser machen.
Das ist irgendwie immer schön.
Ja, aber bei 50 bis zu 50 Stunden Woche.
Überschuss, so muss das sein.
Das war mein Alltag als Küchenplaner.
Ich hoffe, es hat euch gefallen.
Unbedingt abonnieren.
Die einfachste Variante, um immer Geld zu haben, ist einfach weniger Geld ausgeben,
als man bekommt.
Einfach mehr Geld behalten, als ausgeben.
Wenn ihr noch mehr Videos sehen wollt, oben rechts findet ihr das Video von meinem Kollegen
im Raumausstatter und oben links noch mehr weitere spannende Videos.
Tschüss.
Just five head.
Das ist wirklich so ein Ding, da bin ich auch ganz froh, ich bin ja recht genügsam, was
das angeht.
Ich habe weder teure Hobbys, noch tune ich Autos, noch fahre ich alle zwei Wochen in
Urlaub.
Ich kaufe mir öfters neue Autos oder sonst was.
Ich gebe insgesamt echt wenig Geld aus, dafür, wenn ich mal was kaufe, kaufe ich auch immer
gescheites Zeug.
Genau, genau, das ist das beste Beispiel für, ich habe fünf Jahre kein neues PC gekauft,
jetzt habe ich mir ein neues PC gekauft, es muss halt mal wieder was ordentliches her.
Aber ansonsten, ich habe letztes Jahr eh viel ausgegeben, also für meine Verhältnisse,
ich habe ein neues Auto gekauft, also alles das, was ich sonst nicht mache, habe ich letztes
Jahr gemacht.
Ein PC gekauft, neues Auto gekauft, Zeug, mir fällt mir gar nicht ein, aber alles, was
ich sonst nicht mache, habe ich letztes Jahr gemacht, das heißt, das war es jetzt erstmal
wieder.
Was für ein Auto, ein Fiat 500e, drei plus eins.
Ich will mir keine Küche kaufen, nee.
Realtalk, wie viel hast du über, das Problem ist, ich kann da gar nicht Realtalken, ich
weiß es nicht.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ich rechne das nie aus, großartig.
Also ich könnte dir jetzt sagen, was so rumliegt, beziehungsweise ich glücklicherweise mittlerweile
angefangen habe, in den ETF-Plan einzubezahlen, beziehungsweise Plan in den ETF zu bezahlen,
weil sonst zu viel Kohle rumliegt.
Dieses Jahr ist es natürlich erstmal not stonks gewesen, aber ich habe ja die Hoffnung,
dass es die nächsten Jahre wieder stonks wird.
Ganz ehrlich, warum soll ich großartig zählen?
Ich gebe so gut wie nie Geld aus, und wenn ich Geld ausgebe, dann ab und zu mal und kaufe
mir auch was Gescheites.
Also warum soll ich permanent jeden Euro rumdrehen, wenn es eh passt, also wenn man genug hat,
muss man ja nicht permanent wild dran rumrechnen.
Also ich meine, ich kann, ich kann, okay, Leute, also ich gucke jetzt mal, Sparkasse,
weil ihr es seid, weil ihr es seid, weil ihr es seid, okay, also auf dem Sparkassenkonto
liegen gerade ungefähr 35.000 Euro, gucke ich auf dem anderen,
auf dem anderen sind 47.000 Euro, und ich glaube, im ETF Plan sind irgendwie Scalable, wo habe
ich es?
Ihr wolltet es wissen, jetzt erzähle ich es euch auch, normalerweise halte ich die Klappe,
was das angeht.
Oh, Scalable hat sich wieder ausgelockt, man!
Okay, Scalable kann ich euch nicht sagen, aber da kommt wahrscheinlich ungefähr noch
mal das gleiche drauf.
Ja, also, deswegen, warum sollte ich mir groß Gedanken machen?
Warum soll ich mir groß Gedanken machen, ich gebe so gut wie nix aus, und wenn ich mal
was ausgebe, dann kaufe ich mir etwas Gescheites, fertig, und deswegen rechne ich da gar nicht
großartig rum.
Also, ja, ich könnte mir eine Kaffeemaschine für 12K kaufen, das ist sowas, das widerstrebt
mir.
Also, ich kaufe mir nur Sachen, wo ich ein gutes Preis-Leistungs-Gefühl habe, und ich
habe tatsächlich bei dem 5000 Euro-PC ein gutes Preis-Leistungs-Gefühl, weil ich nämlich
Power haben will, allerdings jetzt nicht utopisch, utopisch irgendwie mir was zusammenbauen will,
was sich überhaupt nicht lohnt, ja.
Also, für mich ist es natürlich preisleistungstechnisch so, wo kriege ich das meiste für mein Geld
beim PC, ist es jetzt nicht der Fall, aber es ist immer noch durchaus, durchaus im Rahmen,
und deswegen habe ich mir auch kein super fettes Auto gekauft, sondern den Fiat, weil
das für mich perfekt ist.
Ich fahre hauptsächlich hier in der Gegend rum, sei es mal zum Einkaufen, sei es vielleicht
mal nach Frankfurt oder sonst was, und ich brauche das hauptsächlich für ganz kurze
Strecken.
Warum soll ich mir irgendein fettes Auto kaufen, wenn ich mir auch ein Fiat kaufen kann?
Ich wollte schon lange ein Elektroauto haben, sondern ich hatte jetzt die Auswahl, ich kaufe
mir ein fettes Elektroauto, was natürlich deutlich teurer ist, für nichts, weil ich
fahre nicht gerne Auto, das Wister habe ich euch schon öfters erzählt, ich kann auch
nicht gut Auto fahren, das muss ich zugeben.
Letztens, ich habe es ja letztens geschafft, mein Reifen kaputt zu fahren, beziehungsweise
meine Felge zu verkratzen nach zwei Monaten oder drei Monaten, wo ich das Auto habe.
Habe ich euch ja erzählt, musste erst mal auf die Reihe kriegen.
Ah, for free wohne ich nicht, also for free, ja, ich muss keine Miete bezahlen, das ist
korrekt, aber das Haus an sich kostet auch Geld.
Und sei es nur, dass man irgendwas gemacht werden muss, also das letzte am Haus, weiß
ich noch, das letzte am Haus war der Einbau von der Ladestation im Hof und das hat mich
am Ende glaube ich, das kann ich mir, ich glaube irgendwie 1000 Euro oder so gekostet
mit Einbau und der Station, also beides zusammen, glaube ich, also das ist jetzt auch nicht,
es ist auch nicht, genau, und Steuern bezahlen musst du auch, also das ist jetzt nicht irgendwie
umsonst.
Man muss keine Miete bezahlen, aber das kostet halt, kostet halt trotzdem ein paar
Sachen.
Geerbt.
Habe ich das.
Warum ist es kein Opel Agila geworden, das neue Auto, na ich hatte ja vorhin Opel Agila
und es gibt keine mehr, es gibt keine mehr und auch kein, gäbe es ein Opel Agila E hätte
ich mir den wahrscheinlich gekauft.
Wo warst du das letzte Mal im Urlaub?
Lanzerrote?
Schon ein bisschen her.
Ja, Lanzerrote.
Vulkan, Vulkanstelz.
Ist schon ein bisschen her.
Wie lange braucht es ein Auto eigentlich zum Laden?
Kommt ein bisschen drauf an, normalerweise lade ich das Auto bei, kommt drauf an, wenn
ich in Hof fahre, das ist zwischen 80% und 40% irgendwie so, wie ich das lade, also wenn
das Ding bei 40, wenn das Ding bei 35, 40% ist, sagen wir mal es ist bei 30%, dann braucht
es so 8 Stunden ungefähr.
Ich habe allerdings, also es geht deutlich schneller, entweder einem Quickcharger oder
ich könnte einfach mein Ladegerät und im Auto einstellen, dass es schneller laden
soll.
Also ich habe ein 11 Kilowatt Ladegerät, weil man das nicht sich ordentlich genehmigen
lassen, also muss man sich nicht genehmigen und ich habe das allerdings so eingestellt,
dass das standardmäßig nicht volle Pulle lädt und ich habe auch im Auto eingestellt,
dass es nicht versucht volle Pulle zu laden.
Das ist für die Lebensdauer der Batterie besser und nachdem ich das dann eh über Nacht
laden lasse, also ich fahre das dann in Hof, wird das angeschlossen und dann lädt das
halt, das schließe ich abends an und dann ist das meistens nachts um 5 oder irgendwann
4, 5 wieder fertig.
Das merke ich daran, weil ich morgens aufs Handy gucke und eine Message von meinem Home
Assistant habe, Auto fertig geladen und dann steht immer die Zeit dabei, dann steht dann
Auto fertig geladen, 8,7 Stunden oder sowas.
Also das braucht dann schon ein bisschen, allerdings lade ich es auch, wie gesagt nicht
volle Pulle, so dass es eben möglichst batterisch rund ist.
Hat die Säule irgendeine Einstellung, also nachts ist der Strom nicht billiger, wenn
man einen extra Vertrag, also sei denn man hat einen extra Vertrag und die Säule braucht
keine Einstellung, weil ich das einfach über meinen Home Assistant steuern kann.
Also ich habe mir ein Ladegerät gekauft, was ich per WLAN und MQTT und HTTP APs in meine
Heimautomatisierung integrieren kann, ich habe dieses Ding, Ego Charger, Produkte, Homefix,
haben die für Zubehör, das Teil habe ich, das kannst du integrieren per MQTT, Wordbus,
Web API oder App oder Cloud, wenn man will, will ich aber nicht, das war eines der Hauptkriterien
bei der Auswahl der Ladegeräts, dass die ordentliche Steuerungsmöglichkeiten, lokale
Steuerungsmöglichkeiten, früher war das teilweise gang und gäbe, mein Opa hatte noch
einen Stromtarif, der nachts billiger war, ja, mein Opa hatte auch noch so Nachtspeicherheizung,
hat sich damals gelohnt, so richtig viel mit Asbest drin und sowas, ich weiß auch als
die, was wir damals entsorgen mussten, das war nicht so ohne, ja, das war wichtig, dass
das ordentlich, was ist, was auch immer, was ist OCCP, Open Charge Point Protocol, ah,
das ist, wo das Auto und die Ladestation kommunizieren können, aha, also, ja, RFID, du kannst, du
kannst das auch mit einer Karte starten, wenn du willst, dass nur bestimmte Leute starten
können, also das war wichtig für mich, dass das Ding über eine ordentliche API gesteuert
ist, übrigens ratet mal, was da für ein Microcontroller drin ist, Leute, ihr kommt
nie drauf, ja doch, ihr kommt drauf, wenn ich so frage, ESP32, korrekt, ein ESP32 ist
da drin, also, theoretisch könnte man sogar Customfirme dafür bauen, wenn man will, will
man nicht, sag ich euch klar, ich will man nicht, aber könnte man, könnte man, mal gucken,
ob es da schon auf GitHub irgendwas gibt, ne, ist aber blödsinnig, also die Firma taugt
ja, die drauf ist, gut, das war, wie gesagt, das war für mich wichtig, das heißt, was
ich machen kann ist, ich kann, wenn ich in Hof fahre, also mal angenommen, es wäre günstiger
nachts, nur mal so für den Fall der Fälle, angenommen nachts wäre der Strom günstiger,
da könnte ich, am besten wäre natürlich, man hätte seine eigene Solaranlage, aber
das dauert erst noch ein bisschen, bis ich da was hab, so, da könnte ich beispielsweise
in Hof fahren, anschließen und dann würde ich meinen Home Assistant so einstellen, dass
wenn der Stromtarif eben billiger, der billige Stromtarif anfängt, dass der dann über die
MQTT API das Ding anschaltet, das könnte ich machen, deswegen war es mir auch wichtig,
dass ich meine Ladestation ordentlich integrieren kann in mein Smart Home, so siehts aus, gut,
das ist ein ESP32, weiß, dass es ein ESP32 ist, weil es da sogar, Moment, es gibt sogar
Bilder von Ego Charger Teardown, UI Charger, wie heißt das Ding, ich kann mir das immer
nicht merken, Hardware, was ist neu, ja, bei dem ist er abgefackelt, ok, nice, so, was,
haben euch das Ding da oben bekannt vor, haben euch das Ding da oben bekannt vor, sieht verdächtig
nach einem NodeMCU aus, oder, hast du das mit Steam und Tesla mitbekommen, nee, was denn,
hallo und herzlich willkommen, ah, der guckt nicht rein, oder, und man sieht es ja auch,
GO-E Charger ESP32, also man sieht ja auch, dass es ein ESP32 ist, seht ja auch, findet
man ja auch hier, dass es ein ESP32 ist, es ist kein STM, es ist tatsächlich ein ESP,
es könnte sogar ein ESP62 sein, wobei, nee, es hat NFC, es muss, es muss ein ESP32 sein,
kann Steam Spiele im Tesla spielen, ok, nice, also der Tesla hat auch gar keine richtig,
also keine gescheite Hardware drin für Spiele, oder, ich meine, der hat bestimmt im Vergleich
zu den meisten anderen Autos bessere Hardware an Technik, also an Computer, also der Boardcomputer
von einem Tesla, dürfte sicherlich deutlich besser sein, als der in meinem Fiat, ok,
das ist ja tatsächlich was recht fettes drinnen.
Leute, nachher richten wir die Linux-Geschichte weiter ein, ich glaube, ich stream nach dem
Mittagessen runde, runde Linux-Hackerman-Zeug wieder, ich hab Bock, das Zeug weiter einzurichten,
so, also was haben wir denn hier sonst noch zu bieten, was will er denn hier, 5 Next
Cloud Updates, that will make you ditch Google and Apple, Leute, ich predikte jetzt schonmal
Blödsinn, ich predikte einfach schonmal Blödsinn, Next Cloud hat ein paar coole Basisfunktionalitäten,
der Rest ist angefangener, aber nie vollendet, der fertiggemachter, Mist, leider, Sponsor,
machen wir mal weiter, Next Cloud, aber gucken wir nicht, Giant Look and Feel Upgrades, funktioniert
eigentlich mittlerweile die Suche gescheit, in Next Cloud, out of the box, war ja jahrelang
nicht so, oh, Next Cloud hat jetzt runde Ecken, jetzt ist alles gut, jetzt ist alles gut, endlich,
runde Ecken, Pogu, ich glaube, seriously, ich glaube, ich bin der einzige 38-Jährige
auf der Welt, der einfach random Pogu sagt, was meint ihr, gibt's da noch mehr oder bin
ich alleine, kennt ihr jemand, der 38 plus ist, der einfach random Pogu sagt, ich bin
ja eh schon relativ alt für die Twitch und YouTube Landschaft, wenn man sich das mal überlegt,
kannst du recht haben, ja, glaube ich nämlich auch, Pogu,
es sieht aber tatsächlich deutlich moderner und hübscher aus als vorher,
man glaubt das gar nicht, ohne Scheiß, ich weiß, ihr werdet gleich sagen, das sagt der
Richtige jetzt, Hannes Dankeschön für den Sub, Vortex Dankeschön für den Sub, Leute hier,
August Subscription, ihr glaubt gar nicht, wie wichtig das ist, dass eine Software nicht nur
gute Funktionalität hat, sondern sich auch gut anfühlt, also Design ist nicht unwichtig,
auch wenn ich vorher ein bisschen auf die Designgeschichten geschimpft habe, aber es
ist wichtig, dass das Ding Funktionalität hat plus das in einer guten Oberfläche verpackt ist,
es hat keinen Sinn, wenn man Funktionalität rauslässt, nur um es schicker zu machen,
ein gutes Beispiel für Funktionalität von Anwendungen früher zu heute, guckt euch mal
Winamp an oder guckt euch mal FUBAR2000 an, kennt das Ding überhaupt noch irgendjemand, FUBAR2000,
das ist ein MP3 Player, sieht dann aus wie im letzten Jahrtausend, aber das Ding sieht nicht
schön aus, aber vergleich das mal zum Beispiel mit Amazon Music, bei Amazon Music wurde bewusst
auf Funktionalität verzichtet, man kann sich jetzt streiten, ob es schön Design ist,
ob es besser die Eier von Satan, alles klar, man kann sich jetzt streiten, ob Amazon Music schön
geworden ist, aber zum Beispiel hier oben kann man die Lautstärke einstellen und ihr werdet
das nicht glauben, man kann die Lautstärke einstellen prozentweise, sogar unterprozentweise,
man kann die einstellen und man kann die Lautstärke sehr genau einstellen, wie ist es bei Amazon
Music, du versuchst bei Amazon Music die Lautstärke einzustellen und du stellst fest,
fuck das geht ja nur in 20%-Schritten, warum, ja wahrscheinlich weil man möchte, dass das gleiche
UI zwischen Desktop, Smartphone und sonst wie austauschbar ist, aber selbst da könnte man
das machen, also es ist bei vielen modernen Anwendungen, habe ich zumindest den Eindruck,
also die, die ich benutzt habe, dass es oftmals einen Rückschritt gibt, was Funktionalität angeht,
vergleicht mal, es ist auch ein schönes Beispiel, vergleicht mal Windows Mail mit Thunderbird oder
vergleicht mal Windows Mail mit fucking Outlook Express von früher, da konnte Outlook Express
mehr als Windows Mail heute, natürlich keine modernen Sachen, aber nur prinzipiell von Filter,
Listen und allen möglichen Geschichten, es ist halt so ein Ding, du brauchst eine gute Balance,
du brauchst Funktionalität und du brauchst die passende UI dafür, auch so ein weiteres Ding,
was ich persönlich ganz grausam finde, ist dieses Menü hier von Firefox, zum Glück gibt es diesen
Krempel hier noch, aber ich sage euch ganz ehrlich, mir ist das hier, mir ist das hier,
um ein Vielfaches lieber, als jedes mal hier diesen Krempel zu suchen, ich weiß es ist gleich viele
Klicks, aber ich finde es einfach nicht, oder auch History Restore, da musst du in diesen ein,
aus, drop Menüs irgendwie gucken, ah fuck, wo muss ich jetzt hin, ah Restore, Previous Session,
ja man mag geneigt sein, dass es Gewöhnungssache ist, aber Firefox hat den Kram jetzt auch schon
seit 3-4 Jahren und ich gewöhne mich einfach nicht richtig dran, obwohl ich es benutze, das
heißt es muss passend sein, es muss, die Funktionalität muss da sein und das Design
muss halbwegs passen und diese Balance zu kriegen, schaffen nicht viele, das war jetzt mit Firefox nur ein Beispiel, was mir als erstes eingefallen ist,
gibt, und das ist das mit Amazon, gibt viel viel mehr, was Shift-Ctrl-T in Firefox,
Shift-Ctrl-T, soll das machen, achso du meinst das letzte Tabs wieder Restoren, achso ja das
weiß ich, dass das damit geht, das mache ich ja auch öfters, ja und, das bringt dir aber zuletzt dazu, okay vielleicht kannst du damit die letzte Session Restoren, das ist natürlich noch besser, das ist natürlich noch besser, ich weiß, dass das den letzten geschlossenen Tab wieder öffnet, Quatsch mit so und so, das ist natürlich noch besser, aber das wie gesagt, das ist so ein Beispiel, die meisten Leute kriegen ja schon Anfälle, wenn sie sich, wenn sie sich, irgendwelche Kürzel, noch guckt da, guckt euch den Bookmark, guckt euch den Bookmark Manager, das ist auch so ein Ding, wo ich immer zustande
bei kriege, warum nicht,
deswegen ist es wichtig, dass Software Funktionalität hat, plus sich bei der Bedienung gut anfühlt, und das unter einen Hut zu kriegen, ist gar nicht, gar nicht so, gar nicht so,
ich überlege gerade eine Software, die es gut macht,
Wishl Studio Code macht es gut,
ist jetzt, klingt jetzt vielleicht so ein bisschen weithergeholt, aber ich finde, Wishl Studio Code macht es gut,
Wishl Studio Code hat sehr viele Funktionalitäten, gerade auch was Plugins und sowas angeht, sehr viele Funktionalitäten, ist aber auch gut bedienbar,
das ist ja Teil vom UI, ist aber auch gut bedienbar,
Affinity Designer finde ich beispielsweise auch schick, für Leute wie mich, die keine Ahnung von Bildbearbeitung haben, hat gute, ist easy zu bedienen, hat aber gute Funktionalitäten,
JETPRAIN Software ist teilweise mega überladen und du findest die Sachen nicht, dafür glänzt es natürlich mit Funktionalität,
und man muss eine Sache mal sagen, warum verwendet man Desktoprechner, weil man eben ein bisschen mehr damit machen will, als das, was einfach auf ein Tablet oder auf ein Smartphone möglich ist,
deswegen finde ich es doof, dass so viele Software sich vom Bedienkonzept her, ok GIMP ist ganz ganz schrecklich, was das angeht,
aber ich finde es blöd, dass viele Software sich an Tabletbedienung auf den Desktop orientiert,
man hat doch einen Desktop gerade, um eben mehr Funktionalität zu haben und mehr zu verwenden, als das, was sonst auf ein Smartphone oder auf ein Tablet geht,
warum will ich quasi eine Tablet-Anwendung im Browser-Fenster in eine Desktop-App verpackt, die quasi die Tablet-Anwendung im Browser als auf dem Desktop ist, braucht doch kein Mensch,
das neue JETPRAIN UI ist wirklich ganz cool, das stimmt, haben wir hier auch offen, guck dir mal, das neue JETPRAIN UI, kannst du dich tatsächlich gar nicht so sehr drüber beschweren,
finde ich optisch deutlich angenehmer als das alte, es ist auf jeden Fall ziemlich abgerippt von Wishful Studio Code,
gerade die Seitenleiste sieht sehr Wishful Studio Code-Style aus, aber es soll mir recht sein, das funktioniert ja,
Sachen, die sich etabliert haben und gut funktionieren, die muss man ja, kann man ja verwenden ja,
guck, das neue JETPRAIN UI finde ich ganz nett, vorher hast du immer irgendwelche Custom-UIs gebraucht, dass es gut funktioniert,
sehr, sehr nice, sehr, sehr nice hier, guck, das ist das neue JETPRAIN UI, sieht viel cleaner aus als früher,
es ist eindeutig von Wishful Studio inspiriert hier, Wishful Studio Code, diese Seitenleiste,
ich frage mich noch, wie ich manche Sachen attachen kann, dass sie nicht mehr zugehen,
also beziehungsweise immer hier bleiben, das ist das neue JETPRAIN UI, finde ich, finde ich wirklich cool,
das ist auch ein gutes Beispiel für Funktionalität, ganz gut verpackt, da in dem Hamburger Menü ist auch viel drinne,
aber das ist nicht weiter wild, weil du kannst ja immer noch STRG-A drücken, STRG-SHIFT-A und kannst zum Beispiel hier drinne einfach suchen, was du haben willst,
dann sagst du hier Toolchain, ne, wie heißt dieses Bild, Bild, Tools oder so, hier, Toolset und Bild, zack, hast du die Options off und kriegst sogar higher,
also JETPRAINS machen es auch gut mittlerweile, das ist was, die haben wirklich, das ist ein gutes Beispiel dafür,
gerade mit dem neuen UI, die haben eine schöne Balance gefunden zwischen, das Ding hat unglaublich viele Funktionen,
allerdings haben sie die gut unter mehreren Ebenen platziert, ja, und auch eine gute Suche und mit einem guten Highlight,
wenn du so anklickst, die Options, dass du es findest, so muss das sein, dafür verwende ich den Desktop.
Hast du das auf Android laufen? Was? Ne, du meinst nicht mich, oder?
Warum nutzt du JETPRAINS und nicht Visual Studio Code, wenn dir das Layout so gefällt? Ich benutze beides,
ich benutze das, was für die jeweiligen Anwendungszwecke besser ist, also ich benutze beispielsweise ja Visual Studio Code,
du kannst in Visual Studio Code beispielsweise kein.NET Gescheit entwickeln, ich weiß, dass es geht und es ist von Microsoft,
theoretisch sollte es auch gut möglich sein, aber es ist einfach unkomfortabel, es fuck,.NET in Visual Studio Code zu verwenden,
also ich benutze Toolbox, also ich benutze von JETPRAINS, ich hab mir ja mal vor einer Weile das All Desktop Pack gekauft,
ich benutze C-Line, PyCharm, warum ich PyCharm Community installiert habe, weiß ich übrigens gar nicht,
ich könnte PyCharm Professional installieren, aber macht für mich keinen Unterschied, ich benutze diese vier Dinger von denen,
ich benutze C-Line, ich benutze PyCharm, Golan und Rider und da gibt es nichts Vergleichbares, meiner Meinung nach, für Visual Studio,
Python noch am ehesten, Python ist tatsächlich sowohl in Visual Studio als auch wenn man Hardcore ist und Neo-Wim-Wim verwenden will,
kann man das auch machen, ich persönlich bin allerdings bei den JETPRAINS-Dingern wirklich sehr, sehr happy und gerade was C-Line angeht,
Golan und Rider, es gibt nichts Vergleichbares, also erstens Cross-Plattform und zweitens an Plugins für Visual Studio Code,
du kannst C und C++ in Visual Studio Code machen, das ist ein ziemlicher Pains-Champ, mache ich für Plattform IO öfters,
aber es ist langsam und es braucht komische, proprietäre Microsoft Extensions, die immer rumbacken, ganz, ganz wir,
Golan ist mit Abstand die beste Go-IDE, die es gibt, gerade wenn man ein bisschen advanceder Sachen machen will,
C-Interop oder sowas, da kackt das Ding in Visual Studio Code regelmäßig ab, weil das sind einfach die vier besten Ideen für ihre Sache, meiner Meinung nach
und für alle Frontend-Sachen verwende ich zum Beispiel Visual Studio Code, für ein bisschen Arduino und ESP verwende ich auch Visual Studio Code,
weil Plattform IO halt ein super Plugin hat, würde es allerdings lieber in C-Line machen, was nicht so gut geht,
Webstorm oder Visual Studio Code scheinen sich ja ein bisschen die Geister, ich persönlich mag da Visual Studio Code für Frontend-Sachen lieber,
man sollte nicht so sehr darauf achten, so nach dem Motto, ich bin jetzt ein Fan von XY, muss deshalb alles von denen verwenden,
sondern man kann einfach das beste Tool für den Job verwenden und das sind für mich diese vier JetBrains-IDEs, wenn ich das mache,
oder eben Visual Studio Code, wenn ich was anderes mache, oder Vim, wenn ich remote was editieren will oder was kleines bei mir lokal editieren will,
einfach das beste nehmen für den Job und gut ist Eclipse, okay Eclipse ist alles andere als Winetime,
by the way, warum geht Winetime nicht, was ist hier los, FFZ, Addons, warum wird Winetime nicht eingestellt,
Leute habe ich irgendwie animierte Emotes ausgeschaltet oder so,
weil das ein 7TV-Plugin ist, ich habe 7TV aktiviert bei meinem Vorschau-Rechner, ja das machen wir jetzt auch mal,
kann ich jetzt not like this, nee, I can't, ach nee, über FFZ habe ich das drin,
kann sein React mache ich so gut wie nicht, ich bin in letzter Zeit so ein bisschen aufs Weltkit hängen geblieben,
was benutze ich für ein Tastatur-Layout, Deutsch, ich habe alles immer an Sprache und sonstigen Sachen auf Englisch,
aber Tastatur-Layout habe ich auf Deutsch, da sehe ich auch nicht einen mich umzugewöhnen,
ja so ein paar Basics-Sachen habe ich angepasst bei den Shortcuts,
ich habe zum Beispiel Zeile hoch und runter verschieben auf dem gleichen Shortcut, das kann man ja anpassen,
es gibt mittlerweile auch solche Editor-Config-Geschichten, da weiß ich nicht ob darüber Shortcuts gehen, verwende ich nicht,
aber weiß ich es gibt mittlerweile Tools, da kannst du Shortcuts, Editor und IDE übergreifend irgendwie sünken,
ich habe vor einer Weile ein Video zugesehen, habe ich aber noch nie ausprobiert,
so also Next Cloud, lass mal kurz gucken, Giant Look and Feel Upgrade,
wie kann man das anpassen, Tastatur-Layout wie, ja Bam, achso wie das jetzt unter Windows 10 geht ist eine gute Frage,
ich weiß nicht wo man es unter Windows 10 macht, Kekkel, Hyper Kekkel, Keyboard,
Typesettings, Time and Language, Region, Germany,
das fängt schon wieder an, das ist so unlogisch, wo stelle ich denn hier jetzt ein,
wo ist die Tastatur, weil ich habe ja Sprache Englisch, aber ich habe Tastatur-Layout Deutsch,
hier wahrscheinlich, weil das hier auf Germany steht,
wo man das einstellt, die Tastenbelegung, in den Settings, in Rider,
stellst du das unter Shortcuts ein, in Visual Studio Code, irgendwo in der Config,
in den Settings halt, du kannst auch deine Keys remappen, das funktioniert,
ich hatte beispielsweise eine ganze Zeit lang Caps Lock, ich meinte auch Tastatur-Layout,
ich hatte beispielsweise eine ganze Zeit Caps Lock umgemapped bzw. Caps Lock disabled,
weil Caps Lock, seriously ernsthaft, gibt es viele Leute von euch, die Caps Lock verwenden?
Also ich benutze Caps Lock eigentlich nie, wenn ich was schreiben will, dann mache ich es halt so,
mit Shift gedrückt, ich benutze Caps Lock nie, Caps Lock fuckt nur immer ab, wenn man draufkommt,
das nächste muss ich nachher in der Linux-VM auch noch machen, Caps Lock muss disabled werden,
oder ich benutze, was ist denn der Compose-Key, oder ich lege Caps Lock einfach um,
das ist auch eine gute Idee, also ich benutze für den Winner-Manager die Winners-Taste,
weil die brauchst du ja unter Linux auch nicht,
man könnte Caps Lock tatsächlich mit irgendwas Sinnvollem versehen,
wahrgenommen es gäbe irgendeine Software, die man super oft braucht, oder
muss man sich mal überlegen, was man mit Caps Lock macht,
man könnte es zum Beispiel für Copy, die Idee, ohne Mist Leute, die Idee ist eigentlich ziemlich schlau,
man könnte zum Beispiel Caps Lock für Shift-Ctrl-C verwenden,
weil ihr wisst ja unter Linux im Terminal kannst du mit Ctrl-C nichts kopieren,
weil Ctrl-C cancel und abbrechen von Kommandos ist, das heißt man muss immer Shift-Ctrl-C drücken,
oder Maustaste, man könnte es eigentlich auf Caps Lock legen,
dass man jetzt beispielsweise was markiert und an Caps Lock drückt, und es kopiert es in die Zwischenablage,
eigentlich eine richtig coole Idee, ich meine Paste kannst du ja auf Ctrl-V wieder lassen,
die Sache ist bloß die, warum ich ein bisschen zurückschrecke davor ist,
Copy Paste ist so ein elementares Basic Shortcut, und wenn man sich dort umgewöhnt an andere,
an nicht default Shortcuts hat man ein Problem, hast du ein Problem, sobald du mal am anderen Rechner sitzt,
dann drückst du wie verrückt Caps Lock, obwohl du eigentlich Ctrl-Shift-C drücken willst,
da hatte ich mir irgendwann glaube ich schon mal angeguckt,
das klappt bei mir nicht, ich kopiere, nachdem ich den Clipboard-Manager verwende,
nachdem ich Clipboard-Manager verwende, kopiere ich öfters mehrere Sachen hintereinander,
also ich mache beispielsweise ganz gerne sowas hier, Copy, Copy, Copy, Copy,
und dann gehe ich dorthin, wo ich das Kopierte brauche, und füge es aus dem Clipboard-Manager wieder ein,
habe ich absichtlich hier aus, aber gibt es dann die Lungs auch, Auto-Hotkey ist ganz gut,
aber es gibt bei Powertoys gibt es einen, habe ich gar nicht installiert, oder?
Es gibt bei Powertoys gibt es einen Key Remapper, der ist eigentlich auch nicht verkehrt,
der ist mir lieber als irgendwelche extra Keyboard-Manager-Utility,
ja genau, da kannst du Keys remappen, du kannst natürlich nicht sowas krasses machen,
wie Auto-Hotkey-Scripts hinterlegen und sowas, das funktioniert nicht,
aber in Powertoys ist was drin und den finde ich ehrlich gesagt ganz nice,
Ok, jetzt gucken wir erstmal weiter das Nextcloud-Video.
Moment, das hat jetzt mit Nextcloud nichts zu tun.
Es sieht auf jeden Fall schicker aus.
Hat jemand schon mal OnCloud, diesen OnCloud Go Rewrite verwendet?
Ich habe mich damit null beschäftigt, ist das überhaupt noch gedacht für,
also ist das überhaupt sinnvoll für den Einsatz wie bisher?
Also ist das überhaupt Ersatz?
Ja, gerade die Suche sagt.
Siehst du, heutzutage erwartet man Placingly Fast in Rust, und was ist es?
Nicht Placingly Fast und in PHP, da muss man sich ja nicht wundern.
Hat das Kaldorf-Kalender, das neue OnCloud?
Und funktioniert die Suche auch?
Nicht nur, dass sie schneller ist, funktioniert die jetzt auch?
Kann ich zum Beispiel eingeben blub und ich finde Textdokumente wo blub drin steht?
Okay, kann es mittlerweile PNGs anzeigen, oder war das JPEGs?
Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern, das war mal ein JPEG oder ein PNG,
und Nextcloud hat gesagt PNG ist kein Bild.
Okay, das ist ganz praktisch.
Oh, HiIQ!
Der Editor hat ein paar Bugs, wer hätte das gedacht bei Nextcloud?
Es wurde bestimmt wieder angefangen und nur zu 80% fertig programmiert.
Und es ist auch optional.
Ihr müsst die Rekogniz-App von Nextcloud installieren.
Diese App taggt automatisch eure Fotos, Rekogniz-Faces, Objekte, Landmarks, Pets,
und sogar Audio-Genres für eure Musik.
Und ihr könnt alle Leute, die ihr identifiziert habt, in einer genannten Tab anbieten.
Sie hat seine eigenen Setzungen, um den Tagging auf und auf zu drehen,
und es gibt einfachen Ein-Klick-Buttons, um alle Taggingen zu resetten.
Die Foto-Experience ist jetzt absolut fantastisch.
Es ist nicht geklastert, es ist nicht irgendwie Distributed Storage,
es ist noch nicht einmal ordentlich netzwerktechnisch erreichbar, wenn man sich nicht darum kümmert, was auch gut so ist.
Es ist ein stink normaler File-Sync und Kalender-API mit ein bisschen Plugin-System.
Nextcloud ist nichts Cloud.
Cloud heißt einfach nur so.
Sie hat alles, was jemand aus einem Cloud-Foto-Storage-Service möchte.
Und natürlich, um alle eure Fotos auf den nächsten Cloud-Server zu bekommen,
müsst ihr einfach die nächste Cloud-Mobile-Applikation benutzen,
die sie automatisch aufbauen wird, wenn ihr so wollt.
In Bezug auf Webmail und Kalender, Webmail ist nicht eine Mail-Service auf Nextcloud.
Ihr müsst noch eure E-Mail-Adresse dazu geben, also eine externe E-Mail-Service.
Aber die Erfahrung ist viel verbessert.
Es gibt jetzt Quick Actions, die viel schneller sind, um eine E-Mail-Message zu bekommen.
Ihr könnt die E-Mail-Kontakte in der Seite-Bar prüfen.
Es gibt einen neuen Account-Setup-Wizard, der eure E-Mail-Settings, wenn möglich, autodetektieren wird.
Und ihr könnt nun Kalender-Invitationen von der Webmail selbst beantworten.
Ihr könnt auch die Attachments beobachten, ohne die E-Mail-App zu verlassen und ohne das File zu retten.
Ihr könnt eure Out-of-Office-Message setzten und ihr könnt nun mit E-Mail-Signaturen reiche Texte benutzen.
Ihr könnt dann auf der Galeria ein Name einige Songs haben, die ich uniformieren darf.
Bei derricalen Service tragedy, für alle die noch auf der Selfie-A arada sind,
ja, dann geht看 heute ein rotationiertes Video medios facilities an
E-Mails, die ich dann irgendwie drauf zugreifen müsste.
Naja, der Unterschied zwischen E-Map und was man früher so mit POP3 gemacht hat, ist, dass die E-Mails immer auf dem Server liegen bleiben.
Quasi Cloud, wenn du es so willst.
Also die E-Mails bleiben immer auf dem Server liegen, ich lade die nicht runter daheim und muss mich dann selbst darum kümmern,
wie ich die mehreren Clients zugänglich mache, sondern ich greife einfach mit mehreren E-Mail-Clients auf den gleichen E-Mail-Anbieter zu und die E-Mails liegen immer beim E-Mail-Anbieter die ganze Zeit.
Und das reicht einfach.
Gehe ich auf den Handy, mache die Mail-App auf, gucke die E-Mails an oder hier ist Thunderbird auf dem Desktop, also so ein Zwischending brauche ich gar nicht mehr.
Der macht auch kein lokales Archiv, doch, doch, du kannst, also wenn du willst, du kannst in Thunderbird glaube ich einstellen, dass er das lokal speichert oder so, dass er das lokal kopiert, das geht glaube ich, doch, doch.
Ansonsten kannst du auch einen iMap-Backup laufen lassen, da gibt es extra Tools für, aber Thunderbird macht glaube ich auch eine lokale Datenbank mit Mail, auch für iMap.
Denkt es sich Lua zu lernen? Ja, wenn du einen Anwendungszweck hast, wofür willst du es lernen? Also wenn du einen Anwendungszweck hast, meistens ja.
Also ich lerne gerade ungewollt ein bisschen Lua, damit ich mein neues Terminal konfigurieren kann, weil das hat eine Lua-Konfiguration, was mich erstmal abgeschreckt hat, aber im Nachhinein, ich finde es sehr nice.
Leute, ich habe gestern noch ein bisschen rumgespielt, ich muss sagen, ich habe die ersten, so die erste Viertelstunde denen wirklich unrecht getan.
Es hat aber auch scheiß Default-Settings, das muss man sagen, das Terminal hatte wirklich scheiß Default-Settings.
Hätten die bessere Default-Settings, wäre das nicht so problematisch, ich meine, ich konnte nicht mal die Schriftart resizen, ohne dass es verbuggt ist.
Aber das ist wirklich gut, das neue Terminal, ich habe jetzt übrigens auch rausbekommen, warum es so langsam ist.
Das zeige ich euch, wir streamen nachher wahrscheinlich noch eine Runde nach dem Mittagessen, ein bisschen weiter Linux-Zeug einrichten.
Lua ist eine Programmiersprache, wo die Arrays mit 1 anfangen, richtig cursed.
Das interessiert mich überhaupt gar nicht.
Die Task-App sackt, wahrscheinlich immer noch. Es gab mal eine Zeit, da konnte man die Tasks noch nicht mal durchsuchen.
Und das eigentliche Problem bei den To-Do-Listen und Tasks ist, dass das so wenig supportet wird.
Also sprich, das sind Kaldav-Tasks. Das funktioniert wunderbar mit IOS-Reminder, aber es gibt quasi keinen gescheiten Client für Windows und Linux.
Außer Thunderbird und Thunderbird ist kein gutes Task-Management-Software.
Es ist unglaublich frustrierend, dass so etwas wie Tasks, Notizen, Termine und so, dass das immer noch ein nicht gelöstes Problem ist.
Es sei denn, du verwendest einfach Google-Services und packst alles in die Cloud, dann funktioniert es gut.
Windows-Mail kann Kaldav-Kalender, aber keine Kaldav-To-Do. Kaldav-Kalender kann das Übertrick 17 einbinden.
Also Kaldav-Kalender über Thunderbird finde ich in Ordnung.
Aber ohne Scheiß Notizen und Tasks ist so ein Ding, es ist nicht schön.
Kaldav-Tasks kannst du nicht verwenden. Das funktioniert mit dem Nextcloud-Webfrontend und IOS-Reminder ganz gut.
Es gibt faktisch aber keine gescheite Software im Außer-Thunderbird für Windows und Linux.
Es gibt coole Notizen-Anwendungen, z.B. Obsidian-Notes, die auch ganz gute To-Do-Listen können.
Die können aber wiederum keine Notification-Integration.
Was ich gerne machen würde, ist eine Liste. Meine Task-Listen-Programme gibt es ja jede Menge.
Was ich gerne hätte, ist ein Task-Listen-Programm, wo ich sagen muss, ich habe eine Liste an Tasks, die ich erledigen will.
Manchmal ist es ja so, dass bei manchen Tasks es sinnvoll wäre, wenn ich zum Beispiel Video-Ideen schreibe.
Stellt euch mal vor, ich habe eine Liste mit Video-Ideen. Bei manchen Video-Ideen ist es nicht verkehrt hinzuschreiben,
es wäre sinnvoll, das bis zum 14.01. zu machen oder bis zum 14.02.
So. Und das unterstützen eh schon relativ wenige Programme.
Und das dann noch Cross-Plattform und die Notifications auf der jeweiligen Plattform unterstützen,
kenne ich nur ein Programm, was das ordentlich kann.
Und das hat leider keine allzu schönen Mobile-Clients, aber es funktioniert.
Das gibt es irgendwie nicht, obwohl sich jeder schon an solchen Programmen probiert hat.
Also Obsidian kann das auf dem Desktop, allerdings Mobile gibt es keine Notifications.
Notion kannst du unter Linux nicht benutzen und unter Windows nicht.
Macht es nicht selbst.
Obwohl es kann sein, dass es Notion unter Windows gibt, aber das ist ja auch wieder rein in der Cloud.
Aber zumindest für Linux gibt es das definitiv.
Oder ist das lokal? Webbrowser ist doof in dem Fall, Notizprogramme müssen schnell sein.
Notizprogramme müssen sein, fang mir etwas ein, create new note und tippen.
Länger darf das nicht brauchen.
Selbst das ist zu lang.
Du musst wirklich einen Klick oder einen Shortcut offen sein, du musst was schreiben können.
Sonst taugt eine Notiz-App für mich nichts.
Was soll der Notification im Kontext sein?
Zum Beispiel, du hast ein Notizprogramm, das To-Do-Listen unterstützt.
Zum Beispiel Obsidian, das ist ja relativ beliebt.
In Obsidian kannst du To-Do-Listen schreiben.
Du kannst auch in Obsidian sagen, dieses To-Do sollte erledigt sein bis zum 21.02.
Dann hast du aber keine Notifications.
So und was mit Notifications gemeint ist, dass ich eine Nachricht bekomme, wenn der 14.02. ist.
Das funktioniert mit Notification-Plugins auf dem Desktop, aber mobil funktioniert das nicht.
Feature-Request seit zwei Jahren offen, gibt nichts.
Gute Notes vor Linux, kenne ich nicht.
Gibt es das für Linux?
Nö.
Das einzige, was ich bisher gefunden habe, das alles halbwegs sinnvoll unterstützt, ist Org-Mode.
Org-Mode bringt dir nichts Gescheites.
Org-Mode ist grausam zu bedienen auf Mobile.
Ich weiß, es gibt ein paar Mobile-Klien, aber das ist im Prinzip nur Texte.
Org-Mode auf Mobile ist grausam zu benutzen.
Und dann hast du wieder Sync-Probleme.
Glaub mir, ich habe viele Chancen.
Es gibt leider das einzige Programm, was ich kenne, was tatsächlich ganz gut funktioniert, ist Joplin.
Das hat Apps für Linux, Mac, Windows, Android, iOS, also es deckt schon mal alles ab, und kann Notifications.
Leider sind die Mobile-Klien nur okay.
Das ist das einzige Notiz-to-do-Programm, was ich kenne, was sich sünken lässt mit eigener Infrastruktur ohne Cloud.
Und was eine gute Notizverwaltung ist, eine gute To-do-Verwaltung ist, die Notifications, Termine unterstützt und auf allen Plattformen verfügbar ist, sich sünken lässt über eigene Infrastruktur und einfach auch funktioniert.
Das ist das einzige, deswegen benutze ich das auch, obwohl ich die Mobile-Klien jetzt nicht so geil finde, aber sie funktionieren.
Weil es das einzige ist, was so die, ich würde sagen Basics, die anscheinend ja nicht so Basics sind, weil sonst kann es ja irgendwie keiner, sinnvoll unterstützt.
Kann man auch Gruppen machen.
Als erstes muss man hier erstmal in die Settings, die man nicht finde, und muss die Appearance auf Dark umstellen, weil ansonsten ist Cringe, wer keinen Dark Mode verwendet.
Manage your Plugins.
Allerdings glaube ich, gehen die nur für den Desktop.
Was du machen kannst, ist du kannst verschiedene Ordner anlegen und du kannst in dem Ordner Notizen anlegen.
Du kannst irgendwie sagen, das ist Emoji Selection, das ist neu.
Das ist neu, das gibt es doch nicht so lange.
So, dann kannst du sagen, du willst eine neue To-Do-Liste machen oder neue Notiz und dann kannst du anfangen, entweder Markdown zu schreiben oder, wenn du keinen Bock hast, kannst du auch so schreiben.
Oder du kannst auch Markdown schreiben und irgendwie diesen Editor ausplenden, wo ich gerade nicht weiß, so finde ich es persönlich am nettesten.
Ich schreibe gerne Markdown, allerdings ohne Markdown Review an der Seite, das ist so eigentlich mein Lieblings Setup.
Du kannst hier Markdown, Markdown Zeug schreiben oder kannst auch sagen, hier CodeBlock, Ruby oder JS oder was auch immer oder Bash.
Du kannst CodeBlock machen, Kekkel gleich eins, hast sogar Syntax Highlighting drin.
Also finde ich ganz nice oder du kannst To-Do's, kannst To-Do-Listen machen.
Hier Blob, die Blob To-Do-Liste und dann kannst du sagen, wie ging das nochmal?
Geht das auf dem Desktop?
Ach nee, Moment, war das ein neues To-Do-Entry?
Ach nee, das war ein Moin.
Du kannst neue To-Do's einfügen hier, genau so rum.
Du kannst neue To-Do's einfügen.
Und was ich jetzt persönlich sehr sinnvoll finde, du kannst, das funktioniert halt auch überall, ich muss neue Emotes in Auftrag geben.
Und dann kannst du sagen, ok, das sollte ich erledigt haben bis dann und dahin.
Und wenn ich jetzt irgendwo, kann ich, Benachrichtigt lassen, Z-Alarm, genau kann ich sagen, ich möchte benachrichtigt werden am 1., am 21., nee, heute mal, am 22.
Und zwar um 11 Uhr, aber das ist auch, um 11 Uhr 57 möchte ich benachrichtigt werden.
Save, alles gut, Next.
So, und jetzt sollte ich eine Nachricht kriegen, Alter Max.
Ich bin mal gespannt, wie es unter Windows 11, ich habe es noch nicht unter Windows 11 ausprobiert.
Mal gucken, ob es dann wirklich bling macht oder hier in den Notifications auftaucht.
Mach mal kurz, do not disturb aus.
Also, jetzt machen wir es mal zu.
What the fuck, das wollte ich gerade anklicken.
Jetzt machen wir es mal zu und gucken mal, was passiert.
Kann es auch minimieren hier unten, also wenn ich es so mache, dann ist es hier.
Gucken wir mal, was 11 Uhr 57 passiert.
Und das, die Notifications funktionieren, Mac, Windows, Linux, iOS, Android.
Also, das ist für mich die einzige Software, die ich kenne, die tatsächlich cross platform überall funktioniert.
Und das Gute ist, die Notizen sind auch im Plain Text Format.
Also, die kann man auch sich synchronisieren über Next Cloud zum Beispiel.
Das ist das einzige, was ich kenne.
Wie gesagt, ich finde die Mobile Clients verbesserungswürdig.
Aber insgesamt ist es für mich noch das beste Tool.
Obsidian finde ich cool, hat aber keine Mobile Notifications.
Notifications gehen Obsidian nur auf dem Desktop.
Microsoft Tutu, ja gut, das kannst du sehen.
Alman beim Brodeln. Ach, gibt es wieder Schnee, ja.
Notion, Notion gibt es kein Klein für Linux.
Und ich bin mir noch nicht mal sicher, gibt es einen für iOS?
Ich glaube schon, aber gibt es keinen kleinen für Linux.
Fällt für mich auch schon mal flach.
Außerdem, außerdem, ich glaube für Windows gibt es einen.
Ja, ach so, es ist Cloud only, dann würde ich es auch nicht verwenden.
Meine Notizen sollen nicht in die Cloud.
Deswegen verwende ich Joplin tatsächlich.
Das ist die einzige Software, die ich gefunden habe,
die irgendwie für Notizen und To-Do's das macht, was ich möchte.
Was ich noch sehr cool finden würde, was es irgendwie nicht gibt,
ist, wenn das jetzt noch eine CalDAF-Kalender-Integration hätte,
dann wäre ich persönlich happy.
Wenn man da jetzt noch ein Kalender irgendwie reinbekommen würde,
dann wäre ich happy, aber gut, muss ja nicht, muss ja nicht sein.
Geht auch, geht auch so.
Kann man in Joplin mal ein Zeichen?
Habe ich ehrlich gesagt nicht ausprobiert.
Es gibt aber glaube ich einen DrawIO-Plugin.
Mal ausprobieren.
Warte mal, Tools?
Also du kannst auf jeden Fall, du kannst übrigens verschlüsseln,
du kannst Attachments reinwarnen, du kannst auch, wenn du was suchst,
hast du so ein Ding wie bei Whistle Code,
wo du alles durchsuchen kannst.
Blub, kann dir drin auch ordentlich suchen.
Options.
Man hat eine History, dass wenn man aus Versehen was löscht,
dann kann man zurückgehen und gucken, wie sich das geändert.
Also Features sind cool.
Der Webklipper ist nicht so geil, den verwende ich nicht.
Du kannst zum Beispiel Webseiten darin speichern und sowas, weiß ich nicht.
Übrigens ein richtig geiles Screenshot-Programm, was ich viel, viel nicer finde.
Fireshot habe ich letztens gefunden.
Ist anscheinend total, nee nicht Flameshot.
Flameshot meine ich, nicht Fireshot.
Flameshot ist ein Screenshot-Tool.
Auch soweit ich weiß, Cross-Plattform, Windows, Mac, Linux.
Sehr nice, wenn man Screenshots macht.
Ja, wir gucken mal, also den Webklipper verwende ich zum Beispiel nicht.
So, wir können jetzt mal kurz gucken.
Plugins, ob das Ding, ob das Ding Draw IO oder sowas hat.
Ja, kannst du machen.
Du kannst auch Excali-Draw, kannst du auch machen.
Kannst dir überlegen, was du haben willst.
Kann man Bilder in die Nodes ablegen?
Ja, das funktioniert.
Du kannst zum Beispiel sagen, hier in dieses Node,
machen wir mal, keine Ahnung, ich mache jetzt einfach mal einen Screenshot.
So, hier Screenshot.
Paint, Paint-Screenshot, ich will jetzt, ich will jetzt das da, das will ich haben.
Gehst hier hin, drückst den Knopf und dann kannst du das einfügen.
Es ist nicht so schön, du musst im Endeffekt rendern, dass du das Bild siehst,
weil du bist ja hier im reinen Markdown-View.
Oder, oder du kannst auch den Editor einfach switchen auf diesen Editor.
Dann siehst du, kannst einfach rein Copy-Paste.
Das ging übrigens auch nicht von Anfang an.
Also, also entweder man macht es in Markdown oder man macht es halt in diesem
Visivic Editor, wenn man das, wenn man das besser findet.
Kann man ja machen, wie man lustig ist.
Das Schöne ist, dass es im Endeffekt synchronisierbar ist über, ja,
Joplin Cloud, Joplin OneDrive.
Man kann das auch einfach, siehst du ja auch hier hinten,
man kann auch einfach hier sagen, man möchte es, man möchte es mit Next Cloud synchronisieren.
Das ist tatsächlich ganz praktisch an der Stelle.
Man kann den, man kann den Kram taggen.
Also ich kann jetzt zum Beispiel hier das beste, beste Tag überhaupt.
Create, Cackle-Tag.
So, also wir wollten ja gucken, Draw Plugins, also Draw I.O.
Excali-Draw oder Draw I.O.
Was wirken hier noch halb beinahe?
Nehmen wir mal, nehmen wir mal Excali-Draw.
Wie installiert man Plugins?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Ich glaube, ich habe noch nie Plugins hier installiert.
Kommen wir mal, das machen wir jetzt, machen wir jetzt, machen wir jetzt mal schnell.
Wie installiert man Plugins?
Plugins, manage your Plugins.
Ach so, man muss es runterladen und dann wahrscheinlich from file installieren.
Okay, da wäre es natürlich cool, wenn es dann einfach so,
from file installieren. Okay, da wäre es natürlich cool,
wenn es einen eingebauten Pluginmanager gäbe.
Iiih, ist das, ist das Edge?
Iiih, geht's?
Warum macht das standardmäßig Edge auf?
Was ist nicht?
Das muss ich wahrscheinlich runterladen.
Und dann Plugins install from file.
Excali-Draw, da ist es.
Ah, jetzt checkt das mit dem Updaten und sowas.
Man muss es nur einmalig hinzufügen.
Dann ist es ja gar nicht so wild.
So, das heißt, wir gehen jetzt mal in Markdown rein
und wir brauchen, was muss man machen, um da was hinzufügen.
Edge, exit by running.
Mal gucken, wie das funktioniert.
Hab ich noch nie ausprobiert.
Und jetzt?
Restart?
Aha, wahrscheinlich muss ich es einmal neu raten.
Nein!
Äh, anscheinend nicht.
You can now reopen the node and the plugin will load.
Okay.
Oder auch nicht.
Muss ich das vorher machen?
Vorher hätte ich das vorher machen.
Oder auch nicht.
Broken!
Broken AF!
Okay, probier mal das DrawIrO, das DrawIrO-Plugin mal aus.
Wir sind echt side-tracked geworden jetzt.
Oh, siehst du?
Der ist jetzt auch auf Obsidian, der Dude.
Kann man sagen.
Okay, jetzt zählen wir nochmal kurz das Plugin.
Schauen wir mal, ob das funktioniert.
Okay, das Disable aninstallen wir wieder.
Das funktioniert nicht richtig.
Das installen wir wieder, das funktioniert nicht richtig.
Das wäre natürlich cool, wenn das native eingebaut wäre.
Weil sich da auf irgendwelche Plugins verlassen ist natürlich immer fragwürdig.
Jetzt muss ich wahrscheinlich auch nochmal neu starten.
Vielleicht hab ich vorhin gar nicht richtig neu gestartet, kann das sein?
Tools!
Funktioniert ja exellent!
Funktioniert ja richtig gut!
Anscheinend haben sie was im Plugin-Format geändert, was auch immer.
Das ist halt das Dove, dass es nicht eingebaut ist.
Also ich für mich jetzt nicht so wild, benutze das ja eigentlich.
Ach, hier oben ist tatsächlich ein Video.
Machen wir nochmal das Excali-Draw-Ding.
Nee, das...
Also Bilder ist da nicht.
Wobei, das ist auch ein Video.
Wobei, was du halt immer machen kannst, ist Embedded Draw IO.
Irgendwelche Draw IO-Dinger hier embedden, das müsste wahrscheinlich funktionieren.
Nö, das ist einfach...
Ach, jetzt geht's!
Was ist denn das hier?
Was ist denn das hier? Hello Ex-Cali-Draw!
Okay.
Das ist Müll, das will man nicht benutzen.
Funktioniert nicht richtig.
Also das funktioniert nicht.
Not working!
Not working, not working, not working.
Yep, da nicht, würde ich sagen.
Options, Plugins, also mit Malen ist schon mal nichts.
Das ist halt jeder so sein, was er braucht.
Das ist halt eine sehr individuelle Sache, so Notizprogramme.
Es wäre schon cool, wenn man auch, wäre schon nice, wenn man da drin auch was malen könnte.
Aber UML kann man immerhin machen.
Was haben wir uns hier alle gewünscht?
Dass mein Noise Gate ein bisschen zu aggressiv, das könnte sein.
Ach Leute, ich bin ein Kacknoob, Teams hat doch wieder an meinen Soundsettings rumgestellt, man.
Ich bin viel zu leise.
Warum sagt mir denn keiner was?
Alter, wie sehr ich Teams hasse, man.
Wie sehr ich Teams für diese scheiße hasse, es ist echt unglaublich.
So ein Rotz, Alter.
Jetzt ist es, doch doch, jetzt klappt das mit dem Noise Gate auch wieder.
Das neue dachte die ganze Zeit so nach dem Motto, oh der Max, der sagt ja gar nichts.
Kann man das nicht ausschalten?
Du kannst irgendwie Teams verbieten, glaube ich.
Aber, ja, was ein Crap, Alter, Teams, man, so ein Rotz.
Na gut, wir kommen jetzt mal kurz dieses Video mit NextLoud fertig, also.
Ah, wo ist es?
Ne, ah, wo ist es?
Traurig alles in NextLoud, net, man.
Was, was ist das?
Das ist quasi ein Wiki, das ist sowas wie ein Wiki im Endeffekt.
Das ist aber nur, das bringt es dann aber auch nur, wenn man das mit mehreren Leuten verwendet, oder?
Sonst hat es ja keinen tieferen Sinn.
Ja, braucht auch kein Mensch.
Leute, ihr werdet mich auslachen, aber ich habe mir tatsächlich letztens eine Office 365 Lizenz gekauft für ein Jahr.
Also eine Jahreslizenz.
Ich, derjenige, der immer sagt, man verwendet kein Office.
Aber, tja, manchmal ist es doch ganz praktisch.
Was, was für ein Ding ist das?
Was, was für ein Ding?
Was, IOTAS?
GitHub.
Was ist ein Name?
Findet man doch nicht mal.
Was soll das sein?
Oder ist es vielleicht ein L?
Ah, hier.
Bester Screenshot, besser Screenshot, um Werbung für eine App zu machen, Alter.
Bester Screenshot! Bester Screenshot um Werbung für eine App zu machen, Alter!
Okay, das ist sehr basic. Braucht kein Mensch.
Wie heißt das Ding? Endeavor Tasks? Ich, ich, ich, ich lerne ja, lerne ja nicht
aus. Endeavor Tasks. Ach, das ist irgendein Knoom, irgendein Knoom Ding.
Ja gut, das ist sehr, sehr basic alles. Das kann bestimmt nicht das, was ich haben will.
Okay, ganz ehrlich,
also der Titel des Videos war wieder richtig, richtig mega G-Bade und doppelt,
doppelt Sponsoring drinne, man. Guck mal, guck mal. Intro, Sponsor, Sponsor,
Support the Channel. Also es sind irgendwie quasi und, und das hier ist How to use Next.
Im Prinzip sind 50 Prozent des Videos nur das, was im Titel ist. Na dann, nice, GG Eats.
Heute Mittag noch, wir basteln an unserem Linux einrichten, unsere Linux vor allem
richten wir weiter ein. Notion IO. Solange ich das nicht offline betreiben kann, will ich das nicht.
Ich kann das anscheinend nicht offline betreiben. Oder kann man das offline
sunken und kann es Notizlisten und kann es Notifications. Nee, siehst du. Also, das war es schon mal.
Was haben wir denn so? Komm, eins gucken wir noch, eins gucken wir noch, bevor ich,
bevor ich was futtern gehe. Was ist das denn? Eine komplette Spielkonsole auf einem USB Stick.
Bartosera. Wie würden das der Ami aussprechen? Betosera oder so. Betosera, Betosera, Betosera.
Oh, was hat er da für ein leises Gehäuse? Was ist da los? Ein Fractal Design Gehäuse, glaube ich,
zumindest. Nee, vielleicht. Irgendein Rechner schaltet den ein, warte ein paar Sekunden und
ich habe eine Superspielkonsole mit 1000 Spielen auf etlichen Systemen und nicht nur so total altes
Zeug wie C64 und Super Nintendo, auch PS3 und Wii. Okay, das mit auf dem Raspberry Pi garantiert
nicht funktionieren, eine PS3. Aber mal ganz im Ernste, PS3 Emulator, die sind doch auch zum
größten Teil. Naja, ich habe noch nie einen PS3 Emulator verwendet, aber ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen, dass eine PS3 sich gut emulieren lässt. PS3 war eines der komplexesten Hardware
Plattformen ever, also für Konsolen, dass sich das gut emulieren lässt. Sind da Spiele dabei? Nein.
Also ich weiß es nicht, aber die Antwort muss Nein sein, weil ansonsten würden sie zu Tode
gestrikt werden. Und das alles auf einer superschicken Oberfläche mit Vorschauvideos und man kann alles
einfach mit dem Controller steuern, muss nichts konfigurieren, also auch keine Tasten zuweisen
oder so, alles automatisch. Batus Zerralinux heißt das Ding. Ja, hier auf CT 3003 gab es in
der Vergangenheit manchmal ein bisschen frickelige Tutorials. Bam. Aber das hier selbst hinzubekommen
ist wirklich einfach, das kriegt ihr hin, versprochen. Bleibt dran. Was genau passiert jetzt?
Ah, das war das Intro, verstehe. Das hier ist Batus Zerralinux. Man kann hier so zwischen den
einzelnen Systemen umschalten, sucht sich ein Spiel aus und zack wird das gestartet. Und wenn
ich das hier auf meinem Xbox One Controller drücke, komme ich wieder ins Hauptmenü und kann mir ein
neues Spiel aussuchen. Und alles läuft komplett. Xbox One Controller habe ich mehr verwendet,
wie die Xbox One. Xbox One habe ich nie verwendet, aber die Controller kommt auf uns zum Einsatz.
Ganz nett, oder? Man braucht dafür auch keinen dicken Rechner. Alle 8-Bit und 16-Bit Konsolen
und auch die Playstation 1 und Arcade-Automaten, also ungefähr alles bis 1996, läuft echt auf
jeder Kartoffel. Also auch auf alten Notebooks oder Thin Clients und sogar Raspis könnt ihr
das emulieren. Und dann für Nintendo 64, Dreamcast und PSP braucht man ein bisschen mehr Power.
Und nur für sowas wie PS2, PS3 und Wii U müsst ihr dann einen einigermaßen leistungsfähigen
Spielrechner nehmen. So, aber erstmal ganz kurz, was ist das überhaupt, dieses Batus Zerralinux?
Es ist eine Linux-Distribution, die benannt ist nach einer Käferart. Einfach weil einer der
Gründer des Projekts ein begeisterter Insektenkundler ist. Und das Lieblingsinsekt seines Sohns ist der
Batus Zerral. Oder die Batus Zerral? I don't know. Ja, ist doch ganz charmant. So, warum nicht? Und
jetzt ganz kurz ein Theorieeinschub. Was Batus Zerralinux macht, das machen auch andere Projekte,
zum Beispiel RetroPie, Laka oder Recalbox. Nämlich ein Linux, um die beiden OMSource-Projekte
Emulation Station und RetroArt drumrum zu stricken. Emulation Station ist dieses Menü hier, also das,
wo man die Systeme und die einzelnen Spieler auswählen kann. Und RetroArt ist dieses Menü
hier, also wo man beispielsweise Spielzustände abspeichern kann oder zurückspulen oder sowas.
Und diese RetroArt, das ist ganz wichtig, weil Emulation Station kann auch einfach beliebige
einzelne unabhängige Emulatoren starten. Aber dann hat man halt bei jedem Emulator eine eigene
Konfiguration und eine eigene Bedien-Oberfläche. RetroArt vereinheitlicht das alles. Das heißt,
RetroArt integriert dutzende Emulatoren unter einer einheitlichen Oberfläche. Die Schnittstelle über
die RetroArt mit den Emulatoren spricht, heißt übrigens libretro, falls euch das mal über den
Weg läuft. So, Theorie vorbei, jetzt wird's wieder konkret. Um Vartusera auf einen USB-Stick zu
kriegen, geht ihr auf vartusera.org, klickt auf get vartuseralinux. Und was ist jetzt besser? RetroPie?
Na gut, RetroPie geht ja nur für Raspberry Pi, das geht wahrscheinlich überall. Euer gewünschtes
System. Das ist wahrscheinlich für Steam Deck, ja? Ach, gibt's das für Raspberry Pi? Gibt's
das gar nicht? Nur x6 und 8? Ach nee, doch, da unten. Moment, Vartusera gibt's auch für die PSP,
sehe ich das richtig? Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment. Kann ich PSP für die Vita?
Dann weiß ich schon, was ich auf meine Vita flasche. Wird ja eh mal Zeit, wollt ihr eh mal
flaschen? Download für... Ach nee, nee, nee, nee, nee. Nee, nee, das sind... Nee, gibt's nicht für
die Vita. Das wär's jetzt auch gewesen, Alter. Das wär's jetzt, wenn's es für die Vita gegeben
hätte. Auf Raspberry Pi 4 dürfte da wahrscheinlich auch das meiste drauf laufen.
Ah Mann, wie ich dieses Menü hasse.
Wünschtes System. Für die meisten Leute ist vermutlich Desktop die korrekte Version,
aber es gibt auch Varianten für Steam Deck, etliche andere Handhelds und ein Platinencomputer.
Ja, und wenn ihr das runtergeladen habt, schmeißt ihr das Boot... Hey, da hätte ich ja einen
Anwendungszweck für... Moment, das muss ich grad nochmal aufmachen. Da hätte ich ja einen
Anwendungszweck für meinen alten Odroid. Ach nee, auf meinem läuft's nicht, ist natürlich doof.
Ich hab einen Odroid HC2. Da könnte ich den für irgendwas verwenden, aber nee, anscheinend...
Anscheinend gibt's das nicht. Odroid HC2. War so ein Ding mit Festplatte drinne hier. Aber... Ach so,
Moment, das hat gar keinen Display-Ausgang, gell? Ach so. Ja, das wird schwierig ohne Display-Ausgang,
glaub ich. Okay, ich hab nix gesagt.
Für alle, die dd zu Hacker melden ist...
den USB-Datenträger an die erste Stelle packen, speichern und neu starten. Und so sieht Barthos
Serra dann aus, wenn man das das erste Mal bootet. Mit so einem leisten Intro und ja,
da sind dann auch ein paar unkommerzielle Spiele vorinstalliert. Ziemlich lustig fand ich zum
Beispiel das C64 Spiel Fix-It Felix Jr. 64. Auch vorinstalliert ist der Open Source Port des
1989er Klassikers Prince of Persia. So schöne Animation. Ja, und Doom gibt's natürlich auch,
weil... Was sonst? Also komm, wenn Doom nicht läuft, dann ist es verloren. Roms selbstverständlich,
nur von selbstgerippten Cartridges. Das Ganze zu steuern, müsst ihr einfach einen Game Controller
anschließen. Zum Beispiel über USB oder auch über Bluetooth. Für Bluetooth müsst ihr den Controller
in den Pairing Modus schalten, das geht meist über eine bestimmte Tastenkombination. Und dann
hier im Menü auf Start drücken und dann hier auf Pair Bluetooth Device. Ihr könnt dann auch
noch etliche andere Spiele runterladen, das ist dann aber alles Reware, also keine kommerziellen
Teal. Das geht unter Updates und Downloads. Wahrscheinlich geht es euch um kommerzielle
Teal und dafür kommen wir jetzt ein bisschen in den rechtlichen Graubereich. Denn für viele
Systeme braucht ihr Systemdateien, also BIOS-Files der ursprünglichen Konsolen und Computer. Das hat
mir alles gerippt von der eigenen Hardware, keine Frage. Und um kommerzielle Spiele zu
spielen braucht ihr die Roms bzw. Disk-Images der Teal. Bei Disk-basierten Systemen wie den
Playstations könnt ihr die einfach selbst mit einem Blu-ray-Laufwerk am Rechner rippen.
Beim Teal-basierten Systemen braucht ihr ein Lesegerät dafür, zum Beispiel den Retro 2. Habt
ihr euch die Roms von Spielen, die ihr besitzt, selbst gerippt, dann ist das 100% legal, was
ihr da tut. Eine andere legale Möglichkeit an Roms zu kommen sind kommerzielle Spielesammlungen,
wie hier zum Beispiel Sega Mega Drive Classics auf Steam. In diesem Video hier habe ich noch
ein paar andere Quellen für legale Roms vorgestellt. So, ihr habt jetzt also irgendwoher ein paar Roms
besorgt von Spielen, die ihr spielen wollt. Was heißt hier irgendwoher? Selbstverständlich
selbst gerippt, natürlich. Ja, ist ganz einfach. Zum Beispiel über einen zweiten USB-Datenträger.
Dafür müsst ihr allerdings kurz mal Maus und Tastatur anschließen. Habt ihr das, drückt ihr
am Bardo Serra-Menü die F1-Taste auf der angeschlossenen Tastatur und dann kommt ihr in
diesen File Manager. So, dann klickt ihr am besten bei View auf Dual-Play-Mode, dann habt ihr so eine
zweigeteilige Ansicht. Das ist ein ganz normaler Gnome-Nautilus-File Manager, oder? Links mache ich mir meinen USB-Stick
hin mit meinen Mega Drive Roms, gehe ich auf das Share verzeichnen, das ist meine Bardo Serra-Installation
und in Roms sind die ganzen Roms. Kann man das nicht einfach über Samba rüberschieben?
Doch, garantiert, oder? Kann man Windows-Share machen oder PSSH drauf kopieren oder so was.
Oh, mein Manager ist am Start. Moin, Dankeschön für 33 Monate Subscription. Massive. Wir müssen
übrigens dieses Wochenende nochmal Discord reden. Also, was heißt dieses Wochenende? Das ist ja
quasi schon fast vorbei. Wir wollten doch noch ein paar Sachen gucken und wie das mit den
Geizhalslinks ist. Du emulierenden Systeme, für jedes System gibt es einen Unterordner und die
Namen sind selbsterklärend. Also C64 ist C64, PS3 ist PS3 und Mega Drive ist Mega Drive. Ja, das kann man doch
garantiert über SSH draufschieben. Da drauf kopiere ich einfach alle Roms von dem USB-Stick in das
Verzeichnis. So, und raus komme ich einfach mit File, Close, Window und dann bin ich wieder in
Bardo Serra-Menü. Eleganter finde ich, die Roms übers Netzwerk zu kopieren. Ja, genau. Dafür muss euer Bardo Serra-
Rechner natürlich im Netzwerk sein. Für WLAN müsst ihr Start auf dem Game Controller drücken,
dann Network und hier unten WLAN auswählen und das WLAN-Passwort eingeben. Seid ihr verbunden,
seht ihr hier oben... Ich überlege mir ernsthaft so ein Ding mal auf den Raspberry Pi 4 zu hauen.
Der Raspberry Pi 4 sollte doch so ziemlich alles können, außer jetzt halt PS2 und PS3 und es ist
klar, dass es nicht funktioniert. Aber ich meine, bis N64 und PS1 sollte doch eigentlich auf Raspberry
Pi 4 alles funktionieren, leistungstechnisch. Danach nicht, aber gut, danach gibt es eigentlich
auch nichts, was ich spielen will. Darauf könnt ihr dann über Samba, über den Rechner... N64 nicht
alles. Okay, das liegt dann wahrscheinlich weniger an Leistung vom Raspberry Pi 4,
sondern eher an der Implementierung, die auf Arm nicht richtig funktioniert, oder?
Willst du nicht Linux den SSH mal erklären? Was soll ich da erklären? In den Details habe
ich selbst keine Ahnung. Das ist High IQ Shit. Ansonsten kann ich ja dazu SCP und SSH nicht viel
zeigen. Guck mal, hier hast du eine Shell, da kriegt der Windows User schon Anfälle. Wenn
ich dir in den Terminal zeige, per SCP kopierst du Dateien rüber. Auf dem Windows PC zum Beispiel
drückt ihr dafür einfach die Windows-Taste, gebt zweimal Backslash ein und dann die IP-Adresse.
Wie das funktioniert, wirst du noch. Und da könnt ihr dann fröhlich ROMs reinkopieren.
Direkt nach dem Kopieren seht ihr die Sachen übrigens noch nicht im Hauptmenü. Dafür müsst
ihr einmal Start auf dem Controller drücken und dann Game Settings und dann Update Game Lists.
Dann tauchen hier im Mega Drive Menü meine geradehin kopierten Spiele auf. Schön aussehen
tut das aber noch nicht, weil das im Moment nur die Dateien haben sind, ohne Bilder und Vorschau
Videos. Die holt ihr euch mit dem sogenannten Scraper. So, und dafür drückt ihr Start,
geht auf Scraper und da könnt ihr dann unterschiedliche Scraper auswählen.
Voreingestellt ist Screenscraper, dafür braucht ihr allerdings einen Account. Den könnt ihr ganz
schnell selber anlegen auf Screenscraper.fr. Da legt ihr einfach mal einen Account an und gebt
den dann hier ein bei Bartosera. So, ich habe das hier mal gemacht und dann könnt ihr hier noch
auswählen, was ihr alles runtergeladen haben wollt. Ich mache immer ganz gerne Videos mit anderen,
wo ich das cool finde. Das gefällt mir. Und dann gehen wir einfach auf Scrape Now. Sieht man hier
oben jetzt, dann fängt das System an, die einzelnen Dateien zu parsen und sich die Sachen
runterzuladen. So, Scraping finished und jetzt müsst ihr noch mal die Gamelists updaten. Das macht
ihr einfach mit Update Gamelists. Jetzt habt ihr nicht mehr nur die Dateinamen, sondern die
richtigen Namen der Spiele und ihr habt Screenshots und Videovorschauen und Erklärtexte und so weiter.
So, und wenn ihr wollt, dass das alles noch schöner aussieht, dann könnt ihr unter Updates und
Downloads könnt ihr noch... Ein schönes Gehäuse von Retroflag. Okay, guckst du mir gleich an.
Artflix, das habe ich schon runtergeladen. Und dann geht ihr auf User Interface Settings und dann
könnt ihr hier oben mit rechts und links einfach umschalten. Das hat irgendwie was. Ich finde das
eigentlich ganz schick. Und das sieht doch alles schon ganz nett aus, oder? Da ist jetzt so ein netter
Fernseher eingebaut, wo man dann die Spielevideos sieht und unten links die Verpackung. So, und jetzt
zeige ich euch noch ein paar coole Tricks. Nämlich Emulation kann ein paar Sachen, die auf der
Original Hardware eben nicht möglich sind. Dafür startet ihr ein Spiel, drückt den sogenannten
Hotkey-Button. Das ist zum Beispiel bei Xbox One-Controllern, das Xbox Logo und dann
gleichzeitig A. Ihr könnt in diesem Menü zum Beispiel den Spielstand speichern mit Save-State.
Ja, das ist gut. Das ist gut, dass sie das integriert haben, weil gerade manche Super-Nintendo-Spiele
oder L-Spiele sind jetzt halt wirklich hart. Wenn du da mal stirbst und teilweise wieder
von vorne anfangen musst, das steigern nicht zwangsläufig den Spiel. Was? Schneller geht das
direkt aus dem Spiel mit Hotkey-X speichern und Hotkey-Y laden. Und was auch cool ist,
vor- und zurückspulen. Dafür müsst ihr einmal hier unten in dem Menü Rewind-Support einmal auf
On schalten. Dann könnt ihr mit Hotkey-A da wieder rausgehen und dann könnt ihr mit Hotkey-Steuerkreuz
links zurückspulen und mit Steuerkreuz vor- und zurückspulen. Das ist auch praktisch für so ewig
lange Cutscenes, die ihr überspringen wollt. Das ist echt ganz cool. Noch abgefahrener Finde sind
die automatischen Übersetzungen zum Beispiel von japanischen Spielen. Die könnt ihr einfach
aktivieren, wenn ihr im Hauptmenü startet. Ich weiß nicht, wie ihr das seht, aber das macht einen
echt gut durchdachten Eindruck, oder? Also da ist bestimmt viel Energie und Hirnleistung reingeflossen,
das so zu machen. Dann Game Settings, dann AI Game Translation. Kann man eigentlich Multiplayer
damit spielen? Also kann man zum Beispiel Super Nintendo Spiele, die einen lokalen Multiplayer
haben, jetzt über online spielen? Und das dann einfach anschalten, dann könnt ihr die Zielsprache...
Also man gibt es ja Möglichkeiten, aber ich weiß nicht, ob es eingebaut ist.... und dann könnt ihr in
den Spielen einfach Hotkey R1 drücken und dann werden die Sachen auf dem Bildschirm übersetzt.
Mein persönliches Lieblingsfeature sind aber die Retro Achievements. Damit kriegen auch alte
Spiele Achievements, die ihr freischalten könnt. Auch dafür müsst ihr euch bei Retro Achievement
Org einmal registrieren, mit Game Settings und dann hier unten auf... Achievements,
werdet ihr nicht ohne Achievements auskommen.... aktivieren und einmal euren Usernamen und
euer Passwort eingeben, dann könnt ihr da auch schon rausgehen und dann habt ihr Achievements.
Wenn ihr zum Beispiel Echo the Dolphin startet, dann poppt hier Echo the Dolphin. Das ist ja
witzig. Achievements in allen... Eigentlich ist es eine richtig coole Idee. Jetzt die Achievements
anlockt und immer wenn ihr dann eins anlockt, dann poppt das in dem Spiel auch auf. Um die
Achievements alle gesammelt zu sehen, geht ihr wieder ins Hauptmenü. Ich meine die Achievements
kann man halt mega einfach cheaten, wenn man will, aber das ist ja nicht nur Zweck der Sache. Und
drückt dann Start und dann Retro Achievements und dann könnt ihr alle eure virtuellen Medaillen
sehen. Ist doch cool die Spartus sehr, oder? Hat was. Vor allem kann man die Installation so richtig
schön hegen und pflegen und kuratieren und optimieren, so dass es irgendwann genauso aussieht,
wie ihr das haben wollt und alle eure Lieblingsspiele drin. Das ist cool, gefällt mir. Und
ehrlich gesagt macht mir dieses Hegen und Pflegen fast mehr Spaß als das Spielen selbst. Obwohl ich
jetzt doch glaube ich Lust habe auf eine Runde Space Taxi. Das war nämlich das erste Computerspiel,
was ich je gespielt habe und deshalb hat sich das bei mir auch als bestes Spiel der Welt ins Gier
gemacht. Best Game ever. Oder gibt es etwa noch bessere Spiele als Space Taxi? Nee oder? Tschüss.
Finde ich nice. Er hat, hat, hat echt was. So wie heißt Retro Flag Org? Da gibt es Gehäuse.
Ob die Seite hat Probleme mit Dark Reader? Products. Pie Case. Die Seite wirkt ein wenig
Broken. Ach nee, das ist okay. Okay, Products. Pie Case. Klassik Controller. Also bisschen,
bisschen kaputt ist, bisschen broken ist die Webseite ja schon. Pie. Pie Station Case. Super
Pie Case. Zeig mal. Was ist denn mit der Seite los? Viel langsamer kann es aber nicht mehr sein,
oder? Ich glaube man kauft das fertige Produkt. Die Seite hat auch Retro Geschwindigkeit. Ich
würde wenn schon eine Super Nintendo Case nehmen. Alter jetzt macht doch mal eine hier. Okay,
das ist die Playstation Pie mit einem Raspberry Pie. Okay, recht, recht nice. Super Nintendo.
Ja, den da. Den würde ich nehmen. Dann würde ich das Case nehmen. Ich habe sogar noch original
Super Nintendo Controller und einen USB Adapter natürlich. Die Webseite läuft am Raspberry
Pie wahrscheinlich. Was kostet sowas? Deliver to Germany kostet ein bisschen viel. Amazon.de Retroflag.
China-Chinesen Zeug. Warum braucht man da echt einen Lüfter? Pie 4 wird wahrscheinlich ein
bisschen warm. Also kann man sich auf jeden Fall, kann man sich auf jeden Fall geben. Welche Raspberry
werden da überhaupt unterstützt? Was braucht man da überhaupt für einen? Aha, das unterstützt
gar keinen Vierer. Systema. Das unterstützt bloß Dreier und Zweier. Es gibt Versionen
für Vierer. Hier jetzt allerdings nicht. Okay, also gibt es noch? Super. Wie man an das ROM
ran kommt? Na natürlich nur aus original selbst gerippten Spielen. Super Pie Case Pie 4. Das ist
nur für Raspberry Pie 3. Das NES gibt es. Wie, der hat das für den Raspberry Pie 4 doch gekauft?
Hä, ja was denn jetzt? Können die sich da mal entscheiden? Super Pie 4, warum findet man das
über die Seite nicht? Ah ja, genau so was. Das was du siehst ist für einen Vierer,
aber da steht überall 3. Das ist aber ein Vierer tatsächlich. China-Chinesen Zeug.
Ich finde, das hat echt was. Ich finde das nice. Das speichere ich mir mal. Ich glaube,
ich bestelle mir so ein Case und dann bauen wir das im Stream zusammen. Moment, Retroflap,
das ist wieder was anderes, oder? Moment, Moment, das ist Fake. Nee, Moment, Retroflack, Retroflap.
Moment, jetzt hat man die Frage. Ist das ein Fake? Ist das ein Nachbau von diesem Case, oder?
Berry Base, ja. Super Pie, ach hier. Ja, schon besser, schon besser. Ja, dann hole ich mir so was.
Hat echt was.
Hat was, finde ich cool. Finde ich, finde ich cool. Ich glaube, ich glaube so was bestelle ich mir.
Nice. Very nice. Okay Leute, ich gehe jetzt was essen. Ich gehe jetzt was futtern. Wir
sehen uns im nächsten Stream. Bis denn. See you.